the supreme court
has denied emergency injunctive relief
on the gop
lawsuit out of pennsylvania challenging
the constitutionality of
mail-in voting and it seems like
particularly bad news however there
is still a lawsuit going uh coming from
texas texas is suing four states
so maybe maybe that's the one right
everybody trump can still win somehow i
guess i don't know a lot of people are
mad because
they're convinced you know no matter
what trump is going to win
somehow and admittedly i will say
there's always and there's always some
kind of open window but the way i've
described it
is you know trump is on track for some
kind of victory but the track's got
loop-de-loops there's like trees falling
on it so yeah theoretically if he makes
it through all these obstacles
there is a way he becomes president
again but it's looking
look let's just be real okay it's
looking worse and worse with every one
of these lawsuits but
far be it for me i am no legal expert
and i can't tell you so i i brought on
a legal expert who recently got ratio
one of the biggest ratios
in twitter history i think will
chamberlain what up yes
who who are you will i'm will
chamberlain i'm the publisher of human
events i'm a lawyer
and i serve as senior counsel to the
internet accountability project in the
article 3 project yeah try and keep a
little
closer that way people can hear you okay
so uh uh will recently had a twitter
thread about
which case was it i mean i'm i've done a
thread on a number of cases i did i did
one of the third circuit case which
we're not talking about today the crazy
ratio
you got of oh the crate the crazy ratio
i got was just
because i was frustrated with people
telling me i i dared say biden was the
president-elect
and they were like you can't say that
yet trump has it's not official and i
just want to be like technically the
truth i mean
literally technically literally but
please don't tell me what to say on my
twitter so i was just
that's fair you know okay so so so we we
have to go with talk about what this
means
and uh uh you're not a constitutional
lawyer you probably know better than
anybody else in this room
and many people on twitter who are
opining so we'll talk about that because
we do have the texas lawsuit and a lot
of people are super excited this is it
i mean texas you know they're suing
that's
it right it's it's more hopeful than
many other challenges that have been
brought
but it's still that's still a big long
shot we can i mean we can get it we'll
get into we'll get into it
because uh uh we've got a ton of other
stories too this is crazy luke was just
telling me that the fbi issued a warning
saying that china's gonna be targeting
people on u.s soil
it's not it's not just that we've got uh
this video that was published the other
day
on fox news of a chinese professor
bragging basically that joe biden's
compromised
and that the old guard is back in power
so china's going to get what they want
it's shocking stuff
and so we'll talk about this stuff we'll
talk about what's going on uh portland
police recently retreated antifa overran
them
so uh we'll get into it we're hanging
out with uh luke gowski he's he's
chilling here so we have luke and will
today it's a it's a
it's a it looks super well luke's
wearing his santa hat so it's a
christmas special howdy this was very
last minute i was just doing my grocery
shopping until tim called me here i am
the sensei behind we are change.org
i appreciate sun gazing and an
interesting fact about me was that i was
once arrested by then new york city
michael bloomberg for asking him a
question how are you hope you're doing
well
you yes and uh and ian's chilling over
with the static orb
zoo oh there it is and of course lydia
is producing
wait where's the button okay i'm over
here in the corner i got a lot of people
to switch cameras
yeah we have a lot of guys i'm keeping
up with it so uh if you haven't already
smash the like button
subscribe notification bell the good
stuff we're live monday friday at 8 pm
but let's just jump into the first story
and i will read what usa today has to
say
your city report usa today reports
supreme court dismisses trump allies
challenge to pennsylvania election the
supreme court refused today to stop
pennsylvania from finalizing
president-elect joe biden's victory
in the state despite allegations from
allies of president donald trump the
expansion of mainland voting was illegal
i like how they say allies of president
donald trump instead of just saying like
republicans or
you know it's always got to be about
trump the action by the nation's highest
court which includes three justice
justices named by trump came as states
across the country are locking in the
results that will lead to next week's
electoral college vote
it represented the latest in a string of
stinging judicial opinions
that have left the president defeated
both politically and legally
by their one-sentence denial the
justices left intact a ruling by the
pennsylvania supreme court
which said the challenge to a state law
passed in 2019 came far
too late new associate justice amy coney
barrett appeared to have participated
in the case no dissents or recusals were
noted
led by conservative rep mike kelly the
challengers claimed the republican-led
state legislature's expansion of
absentee
voting violated the pennsylvania
constitution rather than going to court
after its passage however
they waited until the state figured
prominently in trump's loss
to biden last month all right there's a
lot to go through here first off i gotta
i gotta clarify
the lawsuit didn't have anything to do
with trump directly
it wasn't filed by trump's people it
wasn't coming from the trump campaign
mike kelly actually won his race and it
was noted by a lower court uh judge that
they would likely win on the merits and
mike kelly would be negatively impacted
by this
in the event they do get some some kind
of relief
but uh first of all all right you
will just give me your general opinion
so we can break this down and so i can
better understand this what does this
mean are they saying
that the case is done permanently it's
over nothing's gonna happen
no but they're saying that they've
denied emergency injunctive relief
right basically um parnell and kelly the
two guys who were
you know they lost at the pennsylvania
supreme court and they want to get the
supreme court
of the united states to stop it so they
need to actually have an injunction
as well before you know they have
hearings and an argument what
what what would the injunction do
junction would set things in like
somehow stop
what's happening right so maybe the
injunction would stop the electors
from being certified i don't know if
that i think they might have already
been certified i think they're already
certified
it might have stopped them from going to
the you know voting in the electoral
college or something like that i mean an
injunction is just getting the court to
order somebody to stop doing something
and freeze things as they are
so what i read was uh there's a couple
things first we have the lawsuit coming
out of texas which we'll get to in a
second because
this may be bigger i think it is
absolutely bigger in your opinion i mean
at this
that's the reason they denied here i
think i mean i read uh the briefing from
the state of pennsylvania
um and it was just good briefing and it
explained there were like four or five
different independent procedural
problems
with the litigation as far as trying to
get scotus to do anything yeah um
you know first off if you're gonna you
know scotus doesn't want to consider
issues for the first time
they want to see things resolved in the
lower courts and then they can sit as a
quarter of review
the problem is it looks like that kelly
and
parnell and their lawyers didn't raise
the sort of federal issue the idea that
it not just
it would be a violation of the
pennsylvania constitution but also that
it would be a violation of the federal
contracts
they did they did i think not but none
of the lower courts i don't think
right right right like they did that
later but they needed to raise that
specific argument earlier
and because pennsylvania never ruled on
it or nobody ever ruled on it and
supreme court itself would be the first
people to consider that issue they're
like well we don't want to do this
and then there were the additional
issues that have popped up elsewhere uh
standing uh mootness um latches is that
what
lashes right so that's just undue delay
and bringing your case
so that so for those that aren't
familiar that i think that's that's the
biggest one that's basically what
they're rolling on
yeah that uh it basically says you have
to reasonably bring your lawsuit
reasonably within a certain amount of
time you can't just sit on it forever
right
and so there are i mean this is this is
a common theme in a lot of the
election litigation that's been ruled on
so far um is that there are these big
procedural problems before you even get
to the substance of questions about
whether or not the scheme is
unconstitutional in the first place
and so i really wasn't surprised by this
news because i read the
the brief from pennsylvania i'm like oh
wow you guys you didn't raise the
federal question
in in district court or in pennsylvania
at all
they're just going to not hear your case
because they don't want to deal with it
and
that's really interesting because when
you look at the mainstream media's
coverage of this it essentially is
trump is done it's over yahoo news has
an interesting headline here they
they have they have an article that says
supreme court shuts down
trump's campaign's last ditch
pennsylvania appeal
so they're making it's not even coming
from the trump campaign well that's what
they're saying on yahoo so
that that's that's what i bring up here
in this uh in this use today article
they say that uh what was it what was
the exact quote they said basically that
it was too late because they they uh
they waited until the state figured
prominently in trump's loss
nowhere in this does it say trump lost
therefore or anything having to do with
trump
right and we had sean parnell on one of
the plaintiffs and he said
he didn't know he didn't he didn't he
didn't know at all that that
it was unconstitutional they all thought
the law was constitutional and now
they're assuming because they found out
it wasn't
so i mean there's a question about
whether or not the pennsylvania supreme
court correctly applied their latches
doctrine
right but the problem is you know
latches is an issue of state law
it's not a federal law issue and then
ultimately the pennsylvania supreme
court
is the final arbiter of what
pennsylvania law is and so that
that's why you know they have to figure
out how is this possibly a federal
question and again and they didn't raise
it
initially yeah exactly it was sort of
like a last-minute audible of like oh we
actually need to go to the u.s supreme
court how do we do that
and it's like it's way too late to you
need to have kind of anticipated this
potential problem
in this path at the beginning do you
remember what their federal argument was
because it's in there yeah so the
federal argument goes something along
the lines of
um because there's the electors clause
in the federal constitution
delegates the power to you know run your
elections in a certain way to the
legislature
um the and then that's also sort of
incorporates the law making process with
you know the constitution etc um that if
the pennsylvania courts and the
pennsylvania government is somehow
violating
their own procedures then that creates a
federal question because it's a
violation of somehow that delegation of
power but they didn't bring that up
early
they didn't bring it up early enough to
to get at least that's probably what i
think is the reason here right the
supreme court didn't say why it refused
to review it just give it one
right right but my guess is that this is
the big reason so what you're saying is
that you're a better lawyer they should
have hired you
because you would have won uh i'm
kidding not saying
if you're hiring me to do your
litigation right now you're probably
making a mistake but if you want to
commemorate this did you see the lower
court's opinion
on the on the merits uh i mean
pennsylvania supreme court's opinion
it was it was yeah it was very narrow i
i wasn't impressed by it but that's the
thing about being a supreme court like
i think there was some famous justice
once who said we're we're not
um we're not final because we're right
or something like we're we're right
because we're final
in the sense right right like because we
are there there's nowhere else to go
that means we're right so the the the ch
the claim was that male in voting
violated the constitution because it
already has an absentee
uh voting process of the pennsylvania
pennsylvania constitution right
and the the first judge did issue an
injunction
and then when it got appealed to the
supreme court she issued then an opinion
saying here's why i did it and they will
likely win
if it's ruled on the merits but then the
supreme court said nah you're too late
bye-bye
yeah and they didn't even they didn't
need to consider the federal question if
or any of the questions about the actual
substantive constitutionality of the
statute
um and they just kind of get away with
it i mean in this case it's one of the
situations where
you know the pennsylvania supreme court
is there's elections for i think the
sitting justices
i think it's a very very partisan court
and so it's not surprising to me that
they end up
in in this really bad spot and then and
then you know so it's not surprising the
pennsylvania supreme court was really
partisan and didn't handle this case
fairly
and then it's not surprising they didn't
get to go to scotus with it because they
didn't
i don't feel like they were prepared for
that particular avenue but does this
create a problem that like
i mean give me give me uh what's your
opinion do you think it's
unconstitutional what they did with mail
and voting oh i mean
as according to the text the
pennsylvania constitution yeah i mean
the pennsylvania constitution says here
are
how you can regulate here are the rules
for regulating absentee ballots
and these are the only circumstances
where you can do it and pennsylvania
didn't amend its constitution they just
passed
legislation so are we now going to
uh and based on other challenges in
other states potentially if a president
gets elected because of unconstitutional
elections and
the rest of america has just has to just
accept
elections via cheating and took office
and there wasn't like some later remedy
to it we just knew they cheated in that
case why shouldn't trump use
any and all means to retain the
presidency um i mean i don't
think i just don't want to have a
military coup man i really don't
i think that that down that road leads
all sorts of terrible things so i think
you know to me a lot of the problem here
starts with the year before the election
where the democrats are going around the
country and reckoning voter integrity
measures all over the country
and they should have stopped it and we
needed to do a better job of stopping it
we just got
that's where we lost it yeah but is like
regular americans
don't know that's not their job i'm not
going to ask a plumber to understand how
to file a lawsuit in advance
right so so do you remember when uh the
trump campaign sued over ballot
observers
yeah do you see what the judge said
about observation that as long as
they're in the room then
that satisfies election law i mean it it
shouldn't right that's crazy right but
like i mean
here's a real problem the pennsylvania
legislature agreed to all these
these reforms to ballot processing they
were well technically universal mail-in
they agreed to a bunch of stuff
so but technically what what the uh
they agreed to it what they've said is
that we didn't realize they would do a
whole bunch of crazy things like the
curing process and the extended
deadlines and
that's what they just rolled with after
the fact i think that's part of the
texas lawsuit which again
we're going to take a second but what's
crazy to me about the ruling from the
judge on the trump campaign is that
uh on the trump campaign lawsuit so
trump sued uh his campaigns he was like
really giuliani was arguing against
saying that 682
000 ballots were counted without
observer observers having meaningful
access
meaning the observers are supposed to
look at the ballots to make sure that
what the counter is saying is correct
right but they kept them like a hundred
feet away so they couldn't see anything
yeah and then the judge said how many
were in the building
the trump's the trump campaign lawyer i
think said famous very famously a
non-zero number of observers were in the
building
but they didn't have meaningful access
and then the judge basically said
well the election code says observers
have to be there the observers were
there it doesn't specify distance
therefore the
the codes you know uh requirements were
satisfied
i mean to me that sounds that's somehow
law and justice don't always correlate
right
like you know that's that sounds like
the judge is looking at the law
and saying here's the rules well the
rules are these people need to be in the
building it doesn't say
any doesn't anticipate any sort of thing
isn't a judge supposed to solve that
problem that's insane
that's that's actually not what judges
are supposed to do right judges to apply
the law
well hold on hold on i i had a
conversation with multiple lawyers about
the the gender issue in new york city
right yeah so have you ever looked at
the new york city human rights
uh gender issues i can't say i'm super
familiar with new york city in
particular
they have uh they have codified 31
genders
okay but their uh new york city
recognizes any and all that anyone might
assert
okay and they say that in all public
accommodations they
must adhere to these practices
essentially
if you use a a specific name and so
i pushed i i had a question about the
extreme nature by which this
law exists so and this is relevant
everyone just just hear me out this
makes sense
so the idea was if i can say my name is
anything
and i can wear any clothes and use any
pronouns i should be able to go into a
starbucks or go to a job
i can i can get hired at a job and then
show up wearing whatever i want and say
here's my name say it or else right
and they say that a willful refusal to
use someone's preferred name or proton
a pronoun is a violation a human rights
violation of two hundred fifty thousand
dollars
which will uh warrant a two hundred
fifty thousand dollar fine
so i talked to multiple lawyers about
this and i said i'm gonna give you an
extreme hypothetical i'm gonna i'm gonna
take the letter of the law to the
extreme degree
what if i dressed up in a very very
offensive way
and said that my gender was you know
insert racial slur gender
and that my official name was a racial
slur they said that the courts would
laugh you out and say
no way we'll never uphold that but if
the law literally says
so here's my argument if the law says i
can use any name
and dress any way i want why couldn't i
go to starbucks just like a giant
pac-man and say i'm packed gender or
whatever
and then i'm not trying to disparage
anybody i'm saying if the law isn't
specific couldn't it create this exploit
i mean i'd just be less pessimistic than
the other lawyers you've talked to right
i mean obviously i don't think i don't
wouldn't guarantee that a judge would
act on it or see the law your way
but my view is i mean if their law is
really that vaguely written oftentimes
you get results in court
that people think are defy common sense
well so it depends sometimes the judge
is going to do common sense anyway
some judges are more active some judges
are more like strictly literalist and
how they read the law
it's just the reason why i bring that up
is uh
well people could exploit this to make
money obviously
but the idea is when it comes to new
york city and the human rights law
if a judge can determine that my gender
is laughable
like you know if if you clearly pick
something ridiculous meant to garner
laughs and the judge does then why would
any other judge not be allowed to throw
out
any legitimate claim about you know
trans human rights
sure and that's that's exactly the
reason why they might you know why i
probably would end up disagreeing with
the lawyers you previously talked to so
you should so you could actually
get a job at starbucks show up the next
day dressed like pac-man and say your
name's pac-man and if they tell you no
get out you can't wear that you can
you can challenge them i mean based on
how you've characterized that law to me
yes right i mean it is it is really that
vague it says
it says gender identity is
self-expression yeah there's definitely
a lot
of laws in new york city there's also a
very specific law against people's hair
so if you discriminate against someone's
hair or hairstyle
you also could be fined as a business a
quarter million dollars right yes for
doing so
okay okay so not to get off track the
reason i bring it up is because now
now i'm hearing and again different
lawyers different opinions is no the
it's the letter of the law the judge
just says here's a letter of law we're
done
i mean it depends on the judge like not
only judges act the same way
do you think a judge should say the law
is clearly intended to make sure you can
observe
the ballot reasonably like i kind of
don't actually
i mean i i think that's the kind of
thing that needs to be dealt with
uh by a legislative fix because i
generally think that the way this thing
should have these things should work
procedurally as
you know judges just apply the law as
written in their the best reading of it
and then
the legislature tweaks the law if the
law is stupid but but think about the
problem that creates it's like
we say okay we want observers to be able
to read the votes
so we know their scrutiny and the votes
are legit
and then someone finds a loophole and
just exploits and abuses it
so then we have an entire election that
is
essentially not the will of the people
in any capacity
because it was exploited right well i
mean then then that question becomes
like okay well is there some other
restriction or some other like law like
or right that's being compromised here
and maybe that comes into play to say
like
to constrain the way that the specific
election code can be interpreted right
so
but you need to be appealing to like
something else you can't just say well
the law doesn't make any sense
so we should trust the law like that
that usually is not something lawyers
or the judge just says i think the you
know very clearly
the interpretation of the law is such
that people can actually observe what is
written on the ballot
i mean not just to say well there's no
there's no official foot number in the
law so therefore
i mean he quit literally said you could
be sitting in the in in the bathroom
in the other room of the building and it
counts as having an observer presence i
would argue that that clearly makes no
sense
see it and they're not observing it then
they're not observers
and therefore there are no observers
right well that but then the
pro very likely in the statute is also a
definition of who counts as an observer
and who doesn't
right like that's very common for most
of these election statutes
is to have some sort of definitions
portion
where like the french words they use so
that might constrain that sort of that's
a great i mean it's good it's creative
lawyering don't get me wrong but it's
like that would be
probably precluded by a definition so
their official job title is observer but
they're not actually observing yeah
exactly
so the judge said well they're they're
called observers and they can be sitting
in the back of the room playing on their
phone playing candy crush and that
counts as having an observer present
it's it's bad law like i don't know what
else to say like i think that
pretty clearly pennsylvania has really
bad election codes
uh that allow that make a mockery of
election integrity
um that need to be changed now do i but
dude but if you're asking me like
straight up do i think that pennsylvania
judge made some sort of
like was in legal error the way he
interpreted the statute it doesn't sound
like
right yeah you know sounds like he just
interpreted the law and applied it
that's crazy to me i mean but you know
that's that's because how could you
anticipate that as a regular person
you you could go through every law and
make sure okay we're gonna have i want
to make sure nobody cheats nobody plays
any
unethical games how would you predict a
judge is gonna be like well you know
observers don't mean
actually observing the name on the
ballot it just means being there
i mean i don't know like there was uh i
feel like they were in georgia they've
they've list less than the restrictions
i mean covet probably pushed them
further away
i'm sure i mean i'm sure you know poll
observers have been around for a pretty
long time
so you'd feel like it was one of the
better developed areas of law but
apparently pennsylvania is just there's
always something
so let me ask you is this the end for
donald trump
it's not the end um but it forecloses
you know
one hopeful path i think you know that i
think there are basically two viable
paths that we can i mean we're going to
get let's do it
okay texas from cnbc texas sues four
battleground states and supreme court
over unlawful election results in 2020
presidential race
texas republican attorney general ken
paxton on tuesday
filed a lawsuit in the u.s supreme court
to invalidate presidential election
results in pennsylvania georgia
wisconsin michigan
the lawsuit asserts that unlawful
election results in those four states
which president-elect joe biden won
should be declared unconstitutional the
filing argues
that those states use the coronavirus
pandemic as an excuse to unlawfully
change their election rules
experts in election law were quick to
dismiss the likelihood of the nine
supreme court justice taking the case
now i'm just gonna i'm gonna poke your
buttons a little bit and say joe biden
is not the president-elect but uh that's
fine
but he's not he's not right yeah no like
technically not i mean no literally not
but technically is
in order to be literally the so to be
honest like a bugaboo of yours no no no
well no cause you tweeted that joe biden
was present-elected right no i treated
the joe biden one
okay well you said it earlier so i'm
just making the point to clarify for
everybody what it means
president-elect is january 6 when all
the votes are counted and they say
he will now be inaugurated you know in
you know 14 days or whatever
in two weeks that's when he is
president-elect officially because we go
by
the electoral college technically he is
because the
you know everybody recognizes the
projections from all the states and thus
it's going to happen anyway
so it's an m they call they consider it
an uh an inevitability
right okay so let's talk about texas
okay let's talk about texas all right um
uh is this trump uh he's guaranteed to
win now it's over trump no no i mean
so i mean this is a very interesting
thing like i had to learn i read about
it today because i was like well i i
mean this is something you remember from
your con law classes like a footnote
that by the way when states to each
other they go to the straight to the
supreme court but it's not something
that
comes up very often i think i looked
into it there's been an average of one
case like this every year
um probably here for like the last
hundred years and out of all the cases
that the supreme court takes
so like other states routinely sue other
states well the point is it's not
routine like one cases
one case like this every year happens
out of like 75 or 100 or 150 that the
supreme court takes so it's not
it happens and it's usually designed for
things like water rights you know
um like so but like so like wisconsin
and illinois or something yeah right i
mean they have the they have the great
lakes coalition though so they're all
pretty much in agreement but it would be
like i i remember there was arizona
suing
uh the great lakes saying we deserve
access to the water because it's on
american soil or whatever and that was
like the actually the original idea
behind
the supreme court was you had to have a
place where the states could resolve
their disputes
um that's so what's what's this lawsuit
about what are they suing so they're
suing and they're basically saying
pennsylvania
michigan wisconsin et cetera all didn't
follow their own
law election laws all made a mockery of
election integrity
as a result that injures us the state of
texas not just because we don't
our electors don't get to vote for
president it's cancelled out by these
illegitimate
unconstitutional votes but also the even
more important
from the state perspective in terms of
its own interests the vice presidency is
now ch
has now changed and you know we're a
state we have a direct interest in our
senate representation and our ability to
vote there and the vice president is the
president of the senate who breaks ties
so basically so they're saying like look
we have standing to object here
um there are all these problems and you
know you should take this and
actually we think you the supreme court
don't have any discretion we think you
have to take this case
um and then you know going through the
litany of problems that we've been
talking about
they said scotus has to take it they
argued that um that's not
doesn't look like it's a majority view
on the supreme court it looks like it's
just a leto and thomas although we don't
know how the
three latest justices would rule on it
um
that said i i am doubtful but not like
you know i don't think it's
a guaranteed or anything but i'm
doubtful that the supreme court will
take this case and it kind of gets to
the heart of
you know what does the supreme court
normally do it does appeals
right right again it sits as a court of
review when the case comes to it in the
first instance the supreme court's like
well i guess we have to have like a
trial or something right like we need to
have evidence we need to have witnesses
and how they actually do that is they
literally just appoint a basically a
special master which is like a private
judge
and they're like oh i guess we have one
of those cases we have to take well here
you go private judge go resolve it and
we'll we'll deal with this
and then after everything's presented
they can rule on what right
but because they're not equipped for it
they've kind of found ways to say like
okay how do we like not take these cases
if we don't have to
right like we're an appeals court we
don't like to decide things in the first
instance
how do we let's let's narrow this down
as much as possible and so the way they
do it now is
they say well can the underlying
interests of this case be vindicated in
another lawsuit somewhere else okay and
if they can't then fine we'll take it
but if they can
with other litigants in a forum so that
things go normally and percolate their
way up
then we'll do that this is one of those
cases where there are other forums where
the underlying interest being talked
about in the lawsuit can be
can be vindicated there are election
contest laws in all these states
which is actually one of the avenues we
haven't really talked about where i
think there's a real chance of
doing something and persuading a judge
so what is that uh well so for example
in georgia
president trump and david shaffer the
director of georgia republicans filed a
formal election contests
in georgia state court under georgia's
election contest law
what was that that was like two days ago
is that still going yeah that's still
going they just found it
um i think on the fifth so doesn't that
doesn't that plan to safe harbor somehow
like they've got to resolve that
i don't know i don't know how you know
how it interplays with state harbor but
i just know that like
it's the first lawsuit i saw where i was
like oh there isn't an obvious
procedural problem with this
right that's going to prevent this from
getting heard right and that's not
that's going to lead to a judge just
kicking it out of court because that's
been the problem with all the lawsuits
so far like the other side gets up and
says
oh you have no standing and mootness and
like go down the list of like problems
with your
lawsuit that you mean we don't even get
to the side or some of them are just
i don't know the the the kraken lawsuits
i mean the kraken lawsuits got dismissed
yesterday i mean one of them got
dismissed from the bench which you never
see
like that's how bad it was or what yeah
i mean because normally i mean a
district judge is worried about being
reversed on appeal it's humiliating it's
your superiors
seems to happen all the time though
right it does but they want to avoid it
because it's humiliating right like they
don't like being reversed it says they
got the law wrong and they didn't do
their job properly
and it's a public opinion like imagine
getting a performance review and having
it be
like and then imagine being the supreme
court and you're just chilling because
no one's going to challenge no one can
do that that's why all the judges want
to be supreme court
um but so they don't so as a result if
they don't want to be reversed they try
and put all their decisions in writing
and make them pretty rigorous so that
they survive appeal
literally the guy just looked at the
kraken plaintiffs and their lawyers and
was like you guys lose for like four
reasons one
two three four you never could get into
court even if you could your claims are
meritless go away
like it was just it was i haven't seen
that in a serious piece of litigation in
a long time i mean was it
wasn't the filing missing spacings
between words oh they're typos all over
the place but
not not typos like there were there were
whole paragraphs that had no spaces
it was a mess it was not proofread and i
mean what what is this
i mean it's it's it's like they're i
don't know what's going on i don't
understand it because if i
when i was practicing well if i did that
my i would have gotten fired so the
reason
there was an ask is a lot of i hear a
lot it's 4d chess they're trying to lose
on purpose to get the supreme court
there's nothing good about losing right
you're gonna go to the supreme court
even if you
win because the other like again like
say sydney powell wins her law her
lawsuit at the district court level you
think the other side would be like
well we're we're whoa well we're done
here i guess we're just leaving
you know yeah they'd appeal and say it
would make it it's going there no matter
what right and you'd like to have like a
an opinion that says you were right from
the lower court at least to like give
you some presumption like
this this is a strategy to losing when
they lost uh when trump's campaign lost
and i think the third circuit over yeah
i was basically saying
you know a bunch of people were like
that's exactly what we wanted we thanks
for ruling so quickly so we can get to
scotus
and i'm like there is a good point to be
made in that
if they're going to win and they're
still going to scotus anyway then they
want to get there as fast as possible
right so that makes sense sort of but
still
you'd rather win than lose even if that
was the case and you don't want to lose
the way they lost in the third circuit
which was again in all these procedural
problems like things like even if you
won your point you wouldn't have enough
to change the result of the election
based on the claims you're making so you
can't you have to get out of court or
you know well that was that was they
wanted to amend the complaint a second
time or whatever
oh yeah gosh the the way they went about
that was so silly they wanted to amend
the complaint a second time they weren't
actually appealing the underlying
substantive ruling
they were appealing the decision by the
district court not to let them fix their
complaint
um and that's usually that's granted
liberally because you want to
basically ideas everybody should have
access to justice so they shouldn't be
kicked out according to technicality
but the trump campaign had been there
saying we have to get this done by
november 23rd we need to do it really
fast because
you know the election the certification
ball we have to get it done fast
and then the district court just misses
their case and they're like oh well can
we fix the complaint and take another
six weeks
and this record's like no wow
it's too late yeah so so my question
then is and
we'll we'll go back to texas and get to
the heart of the the
that lawsuit rudy giuliani is he
a old crackpot well past his prime who's
falling apart or
a mad freaky genius playing 4d chess is
going to pull out a tremendous victory
it's only one or the other there's no
middle ground well i mean i i don't want
to be mean to rudy giuliani but
he's the most and he's doing like what
many other people are doing it's pr in
the place of law like
i was really disappointed to see
giuliani being selected to argue the
appeal
giuliani is not an appellate lawyer he
hasn't practiced appellate law in years
he hasn't argued any appeals
um as far as i know i mean it's possible
i'm wrong about this and he argued
appeal recently but
that's a that's like a practice like you
and and he was they were doing things
like
they one of the things that in the third
circuit case people didn't miss this too
they appealed a temporary restraining
order that's actually wrong you can't do
that
you have to apply to the appellate court
for an injunction pending appeals
but how do you how do you know this they
don't and you're not even this kind of
i didn't know this beforehand but i i
read about it afterwards shouldn't they
have read it
before exactly this is why you would
hire experienced appellate lawyers
because they don't
they don't have to wait for the judge's
opinion to find out what they should
have done so
so but but you're a big trump supporter
yeah you're you're i mean
you mentioned this before the show that
we had a conversation a couple years ago
where i was like it sounds like we agree
on all of these like you know culture
war kind of issues and stuff
and then i i don't know if he was you
asked me or i asked you or something
like you asked me then why wasn't i
supporting trump or something
yeah and then like i had some answers
back in the day i mean back then it was
like those are the bolton stuff and
the foreign policy failures and stuff
and that that's kind of what
but the riots really changed things too
so i'm like you know what man everything
else i got out the window
but um so so what you're saying is the
best chance that trump has right now
to to legitimately win as per some kind
of
constitutional processes martial law
sending the troops go in just lock
everybody up arrest them all is that
really winning i don't know
i don't i don't want any coups i think i
think there's some possibility of the
texas law getting taken
the lawsuit getting taken and it's one
virtue if you will is that
it only has to get past this one big
procedural hurdle and then they can hear
the case
and what's that that's the supreme court
deciding to grant permission for them to
file the complaint
so they haven't even filed a complaint
yet yeah they've asked for permission to
file it this and people
people are getting this run they like
see it on the dock and they're like oh
scotus has agreed to hear it
no scotus has when they do that they're
saying oh you you
met the proper steps to ask for
permission to file this complaint that's
all we're saying you you
your filing was procedurally correct so
far and then they decide if they want to
hear it or not yeah they decided they
want to hear it or not
odds are the my answer is they probably
won't but if they get past that
if this so go to decides on this one
little decision they're gonna
overlook some how they've been doing
things in the past and is it majority
rule
yeah it's a five-four decision okay five
four because you know count roberts
no robertson yes i know he's a total win
but like that's but even so i think you
know if i'm betting man i'm not betting
on the success of that litigation
because
in general i mean it's the problem we
talked about earlier that
the interests underlying that they're
trying to be vindicated there right
election irregularities
there's processes in the individual
states to deal with it and the supreme
court generally hates having these
original jurisdiction cases and only
will take them
if there's no other place that can be
vindicated i don't know election betting
odds has trump
up 0.7 percent today considering the
news
you'd think you'd be going down but they
still have around 10 to win
and be the next president that's free
money
that's that's free money that's what
that is i don't know i i still wouldn't
make that i wouldn't
yeah i i'm gonna disclose something
maybe i shouldn't i after i
like all this nonsense with the one
stuff i looked on predicted and they
were
predicted was giving me like they said
trump was at 13
to win and you can make a bet on based
on that
but so predict it has trump at 14. oh
wow that's like wait that's way too high
yeah but you know you know what it is
though like it's because you can buy
them
and then sell them when they go up so
when it's at 10 cents people are like
i'll buy it because
some news will come out it'll go up to
12 and then i'll sell out yeah you know
and then make two cents
right i keep telling everybody man
there's there's two big plays right here
if you really think trump's got you know
40 chests
and the kraken was only you know was was
actually hiding and wasn't slain at all
you really think trump's going to win
you bet you you got to go and you got to
place those bets right yeah that's right
i am not advocating the other way right
like if you really if you believe that
100
trump's gonna be in office in two months
that's that's absurd free money you can
make huge amounts of money you'll be
rich
i i saw one plus on social media where
someone claimed to have put like 20k
into betting on trump to win another
panicking because it was like their life
savings
but at the same time i'll tell you this
right here you you think that's true
it's free money
uh yeah i mean then why don't you bet on
biden right now you can do it you did it
you didn't you bet on biden yeah i got
like four grand writing
wow i i'm sure there's a ton of people
watching right now who are like oh i
hope he loses that money well here
here's i actually i have a there's sort
of an ethical thing like i think if you
make predictions like this you should
bet on them
betting is a tax on bs yeah right like
that's a good point yeah you know
uh so you know make a video like series
like you know when luke comes out and he
says something i'll be like okay put the
money down you know what i mean right
like i mean it's it's a real test like
all the people who are saying that
trump's 100 percent gonna be in office
why aren't they
i mean there's huge amounts of money to
be made on the spend i mean you're gonna
make what is that 86 cents on the dollar
no i'm not going to make that much
because i'm betting on biden so like no
no i'm saying like someone would have
bet so yeah you put down 14 cents for
trump you want a buck
yeah so put down 14 bucks and
100. and and i mean the point being like
not that i don't want trump to win i
still do because i think it would be
good for the country but it's like
i've made public predictions that trump
will not win and i feel like there's
sort of an ethical obligation to be
willing to put money on the public
predictions i make
well i'll tell you this in 2018 i was
like i think the republicans are gonna
are gonna keep control and they're gonna
they're gonna take they're gonna keep
the house maybe even gain in the house
because all the culture war stuff was
getting crazy
and turns out i was wrong actually i was
right uh i was right for the first two
days
and then about a week later with all the
mail and mail and ballots that started
finding all over the place
then the democrats ended up winning so
uh it's interesting how that happened
right
yeah so uh so i was wrong then i said i
thought trump was gonna win this one i
did say
i was i'm very tepid most the time but i
was saying for months leading up to the
election like i think trump is gonna win
that's my gut feeling but you know biden
could win don't underestimate your
opponent
so when it turns out that you know now
the election is going biden's way
and i'm saying yeah biden's got this i'm
probably wrong again
and now we're all going like no i've
been saying over and over again
ever since the seventh it's it's 99.99
you know for biden the reason i reserve
that actually earlier on i said was like
97 percent
yeah this was before trump actually
filed the lawsuits and i was like so he
has
all of these ways to challenge these
things and then as he's you know his
campaign and his
and other republicans and pro-trump
individuals have been losing i'm like
he of course still can right what is it
at a point where it's like winning the
lottery three times in a row or
i mean it's just really unlikely he has
to win all these election contests the
time you know we're running into the
time constraints where the electoral
college is going to vote
i mean i you know even at the beginning
i said that the odds have been
prevailing after the election results
came in
like five percent at max well on january
6
the members of congress can contest can
can dispute right i mean and it happens
apparently
relatively often never works and never
goes into yeah i mean that's that's like
what i would expect to happen here
but isn't isn't it true that uh what is
it article two section one or is it
section two article one of the concept
if it's about congress it would be
article one constitution oh no they're
right it's it's about the presidential
election those articles that
it doesn't matter what the states say
the state legislatures always decide
yeah i mean i think there's that
absolute authority is placed in the
state legislatures but i don't think
they're going to do anything to
contradict the electoral college i mean
the precedent there is
is crazy like if you think about it the
idea that the state elections don't
matter
and that they don't i mean i mean in
like
these are the craziest things i've i've
been reading more and more about early
us history
and the founding fathers didn't want
direct democracy like we we all know
that
and we've actually been sort of eroded
in that direction for some time
yeah like the 17th amendment which i'm
sure you're familiar with the senate
meaning making the senate elections
direct elections exactly it used to be
appointments by the state
legislatures right and so senators were
i i think that system made more sense in
a lot of ways you know why why
we don't care about local elections
anymore and now our own communities fall
apart and become detached and and
ejected
yeah it's like our whole politics has
been nationalized like you can't run a
local paper doing local politics section
that's that's a whole
you know no one cares no and what's
really irksome to me is
when i see uh someone running for
congress talking about how if they get
elected they're gonna do all the good
things for our district
i'm like you represent the district to
the to the federal government
you don't clean up your district you go
to congress and vote on
national level policy yeah and here's a
real interesting thing that that the
whole idea of representing your district
that basically went out the window with
the ban of earmarks
you know that was the way they
represented their district they got a
little money
for like little pet projects but they
don't even do that but the issue is
if you want your town cleaned up you got
to vote local
yeah and so before the 17th amendment
for those unfamiliar seventh amendment
says
senators will be chosen by popular vote
before that the state legislatures would
essentially vote the problem was there
was bribery or some kind of you know
just crony
bs yeah i know that came out of like
teddy roosevelt and all the good
government stuff that they were doing
yeah
in the early 1900s but think about it if
that's how the system still worked
then you'd be like you got to vote for
you know
who's the who's the pa state senator guy
who's um masteriano is that his name
yeah yeah you'd be like you've got to
make sure he gets reelected because he's
going to make sure to get a good senator
for us
now it's like i don't even know where
that guy is and i live in pennsylvania
right not me personally i'm just saying
figuratively like you've got people who
live in pa
who can't even name who's in their
general assembly
don't know i i i can you name well i
mean i just moved to maryland so i
but i don't know i don't even know who
my i lived in new york for five years i
can't name a single person
yeah i can name ocassion cortez i didn't
live in her district yeah and she's
federal level i can't speak
i don't know who the councilmen are i
don't know who the the i don't know any
of that stuff
yeah it has been everything's being
nationalized and it's extremely
dangerous
it's not just about politics about media
yes let's say let's say
uh this was talked about a decade ago as
local media was dying off because the
internet was replacing everything
this like it maybe this plays into
the culture war in a lot of ways it used
to be that your tribe was was partially
local
what you cared about locally might be
your high school football team versus
the neighboring town or whatever
but with social media the tribes became
singular national top level and
like very specific right if there they
were they used to write about with with
uh with this phenomenon
you could have a local politician be
extremely corrupt and there's no one to
write about because no one cares
do i care about you know i don't know
the mayor of gainesville committing some
you know crime or whatever
no i care about desantis i don't care
about the smaller town mayor or whatever
or the city councilman
it's not going to make the news no one's
really going to care unless it's really
crazy like you know he built a flying
machine and starts dropping orders on
people or something i don't know maybe
i have to think about it though because
part of this is youth and you know
living wherever you want i wonder if
like we would change our minds if we
were you know
well i guess you are a homeowner but uh
like if i was like personally a
homeowner in a place and knew i was
gonna stay there for 20 years i might
start caring a little more about local
elections
yeah but but i mean your general point
though is correct about how i mean our
politics has been nationalized our media
has been nationalized and the concerns
people have are
are you know ultimate you know and also
like i have a random thing like people
people would say to me like there's you
know i think you might have said this
there's no way joe biden got
80 million some votes like i think there
was a way for sure
right and people people uh were i'll
i'll just
let's play the media game normies were
radicalized
by a psychotic trump derangement media
apparatus that sought
to make money off of outrage about trump
and it created a whirlpool that sucked
in regular people
who snapped and said i just can't take
it anymore
biden boom yeah no i think that's
exactly that was exactly my thesis right
like
well but sports went away like what were
people even focused on over the last
year but i think trump's trump got
oceans 11. that's the way i put it
like the real heist happened months ago
when they were going around knocking on
doors and saying vote when they're doing
ballot harvesting
when they're doing those illegal uh
democracy in the park things in
wisconsin
there's the the viral videos of the
native american women saying like we're
gonna give you money if you vote like
make sure you tell us your vote
one tribe actually said send us a
picture of you voting we'll send you 20
bucks
like super illegal stuff oh yeah there i
i i have no doubt there were tons of
shenanigans too like i remember you know
i was in philly on election day taking
you know
you're putting those videos yeah the
video the poll watcher uh i referenced
that when
we had destiny here he's a leftist and
he said if these claims of of like
irregularity and
and and front of tough were or the
observers being blocked were true then
where were all the videos on election
night and i was like well chamberlain
was there and he posted
like a video in the morning of like an
observer being kicked out yeah it
happened
yeah that's weird like there were so
many people who just a random side note
so many people denied that like i got i
saw fact checks that were like
yeah there was there was buzzfeed tried
to fact check i literally corrected her
and she withdrew it to her credit
yeah like you know so he wasn't you know
and then
they tried claiming that knows he was at
the wrong precinct or whatever right
it's like and then you posted the photo
where it's like good in any precinct
right exactly so weird they they just
they were so tuned for like oh there's
misinformation people are going to
spread misinformation i'm like
you guys know there's actual shenanigans
going on in philly and i don't know that
there was some like massive plot to like
poll watching it's more like that you
know what what i would attribute this
particular thing to was just sort of an
arrogance among the
po the poll workers in that area that
like they were kings of the castle they
dictated what happened they didn't need
a paper but they they they
did you see the video where the guy
yells all republican paul watchers
leave now or whatever i didn't see that
one but yeah yeah yeah there's there's
stuff like that there
or they're putting up boards to block
the windows do you see what scott adams
said about this
what he said if you are having a
discussion
about the potential irregularities or
fraud
after they barred observers and blocked
windows you're a victim of
misinformation
and essentially misdirection yeah
because as soon as they said no
witnesses
there's you can't do anything after that
right so when they when they say where's
the evidence of fraud i don't know they
kicked out the observers and boarded the
windows up right and i'm actually for
like as a general rule like the idea
that if you if you wrongfully kick out
poll watchers and the votes go away
right
we'd like we assume we assume you've
committed fraud the presumption is you
committed fraud and you need to
affirmatively prove you didn't right yes
like i mean that's you know like that's
how it kind of works in the court system
generally like if you fail to produce
something of litigation judges will
issue it
eventually issue an adverse inference
instruction saying jury you need to
assume that this was terrible evidence
for them that proved that they did
something horrible
interesting um you know and that's the
way i should look at i think we should
look at
but we need to change the law to do this
right but i think we should change the
law about poll watchers
and and get people to a point where when
they are instructed about working a poll
and letting a pole watcher in there like
we better not
restrict this poll watcher because the
consequences of doing so are terrible
well that's clearly not the case in
philly the consequences of what we're
talking about go well beyond just
the election and which team won right
what people need to realize and i i i've
been saying
quite a bit is that we're a nation of
people a judge could rule something
that's ridiculous and dumb
and it would stand because they're the
judge and if it's a supreme court
justice who gives a bad ruling then what
do they do
right it ends with them people aren't
computers they're not robots
and so i was mentioning this previously
that people keep saying
here's what the safe harbor provision
says therefore we've won
and i'm like you could get a crazy
justice who's like you know he just goes
nuts and gives some crazy ruling
and i'm within reason obviously like
within the confines of law i just have a
weird interpretation of it
and then you get a weird ruling you
didn't expect because people make the
decisions not computers it's not a code
you know what i mean right and i mean
like that's why you know for example the
texas lawsuit still has a chance i
wouldn't rule it out
right like there's always some human
variability yeah you know
there's there's cases where you have
better odds and worse odds right if
you're fighting
six different procedural arguments that
a judge has to decide
oh well i'm just gonna have to ignore
the law in like six different core areas
of our jurisprudence in order to rule
for you they're just not gonna they
don't wanna do that
what are what are the odds you would
give trump of winning right now
yes less than one percent wow but more
than
more than 0.01
you know i mean those are pretty those
are still like not bad odds to be honest
i mean you know he he he's not ahead in
the vote counts in like four different
states i mean and the problem is he has
to win
you know one of the reasons i'll talk
about the other reason i like the texas
lawsuit he has to win in four different
states or he has to flip four different
states or win one lawsuit from texas and
generally
yeah exactly right with a lawsuit in
texas at least it's elegant in the sense
of a chance to just
in one shot get rid of all the problems
but otherwise he has to win independent
election contests
and foreign it is time running it's like
it's like in a movie
and there's like four bad guys and then
like
texas comes up and he pulls out his gun
and goes bam bam bam bam bam and then
just knocks them all out at once and
then
when the gun who puts it away that's
texas that's that's the hope
like i'm hoping for that i really am i
hope to lose the four grand i bet on
biden
and be revealed to be a complete
charlatan as a result
no no no i think you know it's it's it's
it's annoying to me that people think
you're not allowed to be wrong when you
make predictions it's like you can be
wrong whatever like
at the time you had you had made it an
educated guess based on the evidence
laid before you
laid before you and there's a lot of
variables and there you go
so so i'll tell you this man long story
short i had a buddy tell me in 2011 not
to buy bitcoin when i was at 70 cents
because he said it's you can't do
anything with it it's hard to get
if you make this purchase now you'll be
putting a bunch of your money into
something you can't get out and then
what happens in a month when everyone
forgets about it you'll have nothing
that's actually a really good argument
so i said better not buy it
if i had spent the five grand on 70 cent
bitcoin
i would be very very happy today if i
didn't but it was it would have been
stupid for me to take it was basically
my life savings
and putting it in bitcoin i was like
this new technology this is amazing
you're reading about this stuff i'm
really excited and he's like don't do it
man
you need that money now for food and i'm
like yeah you're right
as i was telling that a month later a
month later is it before i met you
no no even afterwards when bitcoin was
out there i was like you got to get into
bitcoin you got to do it
i was buying i i have bitcoin yeah i've
been paying attention
but anyway here's what here's what i'm
saying this election is not just about
which team won right it's about
at this point i think this is maybe the
most consequential election we've ever
had
so here's the next story that we're
going to get into trump tweets video of
chinese professor claiming that beijing
can swing u.s policy
because it has people at the top of
america's core inner circle of power
in clip that has been deleted from
social media in china not only
does this guy dong chang say that they
have uh
they have old friends he calls it in
high positions
he says that joe biden's son became rich
with all this international financing
stuff and
who do you think helped him do it
essentially in
saying the bidens are compromised but he
doesn't need to say it because tony
babilinski
already said it yeah that joe biden is
compromised by china and now we have a
guy
in china they're all laughing as he says
he did it this is
this is the consequence now of losing
this election yeah no i'm
i'm really not happy about that you know
and i think
but so listen listen what do you do
what do you do uh you you try and beat
him or i mean
or well and one of the things i've been
talking about has been let's get a
special counsel going
right like this is what democrats did
let's have a special counselor for bain
and
biden and china and if they if the end
of the election
and the election yeah let's have a
second like we should have three right
there's durham already
but let's have a new one for the china
barisma stuff
and let's have one for the election
irregularities and let's make the
democrats adhere you know if the
democrats want like
obviously a democrat attorney general
can figure out a way to fire these
people there are ways yeah but if they
want to set that precedent fine we're
never going to have to deal with another
bs investigation from the civil service
again right and so i mean i think they
probably will end up doing that if we
took the you know if barr pulled the
trigger was it was it look was it lebron
james
who came out all pro china was yeah yeah
we've been seeing more and more u.s
companies capitulate to china
authoritarian despots communists who
harvest organs from religious minorities
and they're bragging now that they've
essentially got
the incoming president in their back
pocket yeah it's kind of funny how like
the communist government of china ended
up proving every critique of capitalism
true
uh right like yeah you you end up with
i mean all the worst sort of
rapaciousness and corruption
they were able to go to these these
harvard professors these what
what what are the universities where
they arrested all these guys oh yeah i
mean it was harvard berkeley i think had
one
they go to professor and say hey we'll
give you 50 000 a month give us your
secrets
recruit for us and they say you bet oh
man not only to them but to u.s soldiers
to military personnel with top secret
clearances just like that nypd officer
that was taken in
and also other governments like israel
that have sold u.s technology
to china so this is a major issue that's
going to have major implications i want
to know
who is this top american core uh the
inner circle of power
influence who are these people i want i
want to know there deserves to be an
investigation
deep state well here you go top level
well
let's call the old friends i'm going to
call them the old friends from now on
talk about
wall street and how wall street was able
to contain someone like obama that was
very easy to manipulate and then he said
when trump came in
the story wasn't uh so true and then he
thinks that when binding comes in things
are gonna go back to normal what's
normal what is this normal according to
beijing and the chinese
government the pinky ring of the chinese
communist party yeah
trump wouldn't do it this guy was like
how do we fix the trump administration
we couldn't do it
well then biden won and everyone laughs
everyone laughs
so look uh sam harris tweeted the other
day the story from the new york times
why do so many people think the election
was rigged
and jeffrey miller so nothing's another
professor responded that when when
there's so much anti-conservative bias
in academia and institutions in the
media
people just don't trust the elections
right but it's crazy to me that
we have joe biden the single greatest
president in american history
um based on his ability i mean you have
to imagine um
the amount of votes he got 80 million
and and the amount of campaigning he did
basically none he must have been the
most
powerfully charismatic individual i can
only imagine when he when he
got up on tv and he said come on man
every single
you know one of these voters just like
was blasted back by the pure uh
awe of joe biden's charisma i don't know
i mean he
you know hillary was a really bad
candidate in a lot of ways people really
didn't like hillary clinton and they had
really good reason not to like her
you know the thing about biden he's a
goofball
he's in cognitive decline but nobody
hated him
right right he's not as trump trump was
a threat
he it's like who loathes joe biden
there might be a few people like and
maybe he's done some really low some
things like with chyna
scott but like tara reid yeah tara reid
i mean
yeah you know there there are there are
certainly scandals that are loathsome
but personality wise he he's not like
hillary and he's not like a lot of
democrats who are just
you know well so so let me ask you this
let me let me uh load the the question
up a little bit
joe biden beat every non-polling
bellwether metric
such as voter enthusiasm party
registration numbers
uh google searches which is a new one
there's a primary vote count and support
he also won the other silly ones like
cookie sales and mass
i'm sorry he lost or you're talking
about yeah trump won all these and biden
by didn't beat them he
he so basically all of these things
weren't against him so
whoever gets the heist enthusiasm tends
to win whoever gets the best primary
turnout tends to win whoever gets the
most
um new registration tends to win whoever
sells the most halloween masks and most
cookies those are the silly ones i bring
them up on purpose
joe biden lost all of those things and
still won he lost the three bellwether
states and 18 of 19 below the townships
so when you say all that a lot of people
say
look if you came up to me and said he
beat a few of these things i'd be like
wow
you come on you tell me that he beat
every single one of them
at once and that's the weird i mean it's
it's weird and i think i think certainly
there is not impossible but
it's just not impossible and in 2020 was
a different election
it's true it's true what i always often
say people got to realize too is that
kovit moved everybody around
that people were moving and the riots
moved everybody around so that could
explain the states and
the townships i suppose but we also have
to understand that who was in biden's
corner
china was in his corner the big tech
monopolies were in this corner
hollywood was in his corner the
mainstream media was in his
establishment the establishment was in
his
you know corner and they all are working
together helping each other out so it
makes you really wonder what really
happened here especially with the latest
revelations
from this professor from beijing i mean
this is mind-blowing stuff
did you i mean what he said about hunter
and how the hunter story was
treated in the united states it was
essentially stuffed out
the american public were denied the
truth about the hunter biden emails
because of the mainstream media and big
tech social monopolies
collusion destroying it this is what the
professor said
trump has been saying that biden's son
has some sort of global foundation
have you noticed that who helped hunter
build
the foundation got it there are a lot of
these
deals inside you know you need to
understand the way he said it yes
the laughing and smiling he didn't just
say and who helped him build it got it
he went
and who helped him built it yeah and
everyone laughs got it
right our old friends the political
establishment the elites the old guard
the people who are in government who are
helping us out he says
i talked to our friends they said they
were trying to help but they couldn't
stop trump
right well then biden gets biden wins he
smiles and everyone laughs
so look man i'm uh i'm not uh
i i think i think dark times are coming
dark winter is
is is putting it lightly i mean i i hope
that we win the georgia senate races
really really badly i think i don't
think so well a lot of republicans are
disenfranchised
because you know trump's being kind of
quiet he's not really being bombastic
he's not really fighting and then
everything just looks like it's not
going his way so
but trump's not on the ticket yet but
people don't like the republicans
i mean in georgia right like you know
the the senate candidates outperformed
trump
right but like lawfully was appointed
yeah i mean they're not there's not
huge enthusiasm behind them but right
you know the sort of she
she didn't win a popularity contest
right yeah i mean there's a vacancy
outright but like there were there are
overall more republican votes in both
the senate seats i think it's still
pretty viable for us to win those senate
seats
i i agree i'm just leaning towards and
maybe i'll be wrong again because
you know i'm not good at predicting how
people vote i suppose uh or i
am and i'm not good at predicting how
fraud plays out um but that's the case
that democrats win
i don't know i mean like like base i i
speak to some personal experience like
my parents are classic suburban
republicans right and they
uh my mom couldn't stand trump she just
couldn't right you know and yeah they
voted for hillary and voted for biden um
but even she called me the other day and
said i'm like i'm
i really you know i'm really still glad
trump went to georgia to get those
republican senate candidates elected
like there
there really are there really is that
constituency of people
um in in certain places like georgia
that
just couldn't couldn't stomach trump but
would generally want republicans in
power
well let's let's talk about the more
severe reality of what comes next
this is from uh we got yahoo news fbi
warns state
local police about china targeting
people on u.s soil
they say the fbi is warning local law
enforcement agencies to beware of
cooperating with a chinese government
campaign
to coerce u.s residents to return to
china
to face criminal charges according to a
counterintelligence bulletin obtained by
yahoo news
the bulletin comes shortly after eight
people including a former new york
police department officer were indicted
on charges of acting as a legal agents
for beijing
eight people including a new nypd
officer
were i mean how is this not treason
well he wasn't just an nypd officer it's
he also held a very
important security clearance because he
was in the military as well
in the us military in the u.s military
as well and he was spying on the tibetan
community
which was a protest community that he
was going back all the way to china
giving out key information who was a
part of organizing against the chinese
government
do you see what mike pompeo said earlier
this year i'm not i mean
he said a lot of things he said china's
infiltrated every level of government
from the state city that's very true
so i i feel like this guy getting up on
stage
in china and gloating that the bidens
are basically
in the pockets of the old friends and
seeing the story about hunter biden let
me just make something really really
clear
joe biden took hunter bite on an air
force 2 to china for a private equity
deal
why did joe biden use u.s government
resources
to help his son get a 5 million
forgivable
interest-free loan from china and launch
a you know billion dollar
billion equity firm they're they're in
the pocket it's beijing
bobby linski who worked with the family
gave an interview saying they're
compromised
and that's it yeah we just roll over and
say we we're all chinese subjects now
second-class citizens nonetheless
because we can't even go to china i mean
china poses such a difficult problem
like i i often people think like it was
just obvious
that you know we were gonna win the cold
war i mean we had a massive espionage
disadvantage of the soviet union yeah
um but ultimately the soviet union was
you know fighting us but they had
a completely dysfunctional economic
system they couldn't put enough toilet
paper on the shelves
you know they didn't can't put enough
toilet paper on the shelves now yeah i
mean
right um but like it took 50 years to
beat that that
economy and that economy was completely
dysfunctional china's economy is not
dysfunctional
no um it's manipulative it's
manipulative
and they and they're also have the same
sort of like espionage superiority of us
that the soviets have arrested
they have four times the people four
times the people i mean in terms of
agents like we don't have any meaningful
presence there they have i mean
there's some great books on this um
about what the var variety of different
operations china's running here
um trying to hack lower level defense
contractors because they can't hack
obviously this you know dod but they try
and get low-level contractors and get
plans that way
you know basically trying to recruit
people i mean there are
i think something that somebody said to
me or i think i might have read it
there are like serious technical
computer science programs at college
park
taught by chinese professors to chinese
students in chinese
and that's weird like that's and then
those kids go back
they're they're they're they're
manipulating their uh real estate market
in china
yeah to create this this like a regular
middle-class house is like a million
dollars compared to an
american which is you know 200 300 000
or something like that they're buying up
large swaths of land
in countries all over the world in uh in
brazil in in africa
in uh in the u.s on the west on the west
coast they're buying up tons and tons of
property
they're just slowly buying their way to
take everything over yeah
it's clever it's basically they've
convinced the united states to give up
all its manufacturing in exchange for
cheap labor
these politicians we've had over the
past several decades the old friends as
as
dee dong chang says have uh thought to
themselves
look it's good for the american business
to have
dollar an hour chinese laborers i've got
to pay benefits to they save money and
we all get rich
and then a generation goes by decade
goes by and now we no longer make our
own medicine
we don't like you buy a musical
instrument you buy you know
computer computers cameras whatever it's
all made somewhere else we don't make it
anymore
what would happen if china declared war
right now we'd be caught with our pants
down i mean
it's i mean they wouldn't i mean there's
they're still the mutual assure
destruction worries but i mean they
were beyond the point of being able to
you know really meaningfully coerce them
like that's and that's that's actually
different from like where we were as a
superpower even 20 years ago
um like and and that's sort of we know
we at human events i mean we ran an
article
like xi jinping will have his way in
hong kong and i was like two years ago
yeah we got a lot of flak from that from
people who were saying
but like we you know again a descriptive
versus a narrative argument do i want xi
jinping to have his way with hong kong
no will he yes exactly this beijing
professor confirmed everything that
we've been hearing about fair version we
were talking about this two days ago
before two years
ago we were breaking everything down and
we got to understand we're in the trade
war we're going to going to be in a
currency war where
probably according to the cesidius trap
might be even in a hot war
and we have to understand china has its
hands deep
in american institutions like we can't
even imagine
when we look at politicians and
corporations they have been
enriched more than they could have even
imagined because of this opening of
china policy that has been instituted by
individuals like henry kissinger under
the nixon administration
that literally went to china with david
rockefeller and said
hey we're going to have a lot of jobs
for you we're going to bring you a lot
of factories we're going to bring you a
lot of industry
you just give us the cheap chinese slave
labor and then we're going to have a
great deal and all everything's going to
go through china and that's exactly
what's happening right now look look
it's it's beyond just the schools where
they have a thousand towns project where
they've actually
got a bunch of professors taking 50k a
month or whatever recruiting more people
and selling our secrets
they're they've got hollywood bending
the knee doing movies where they removed
negative things that could offend china
the nba is praising them and they got
tick-tock and mainstream media as well
mainstream news articles refused many
times to even criticize
china or the uyghur muslims i mean look
at tibet
as an example a few years ago everyone
was talking about
tibet and the tibetans and the things
that they're going through with the
chinese government
now no one's even talking about tibet no
one's talking about the uyghur muslims
nobody's talking about
the hong kong where we're getting video
footage right now of them
sending activists and protesters to
mainland china to never be seen
again or the video footage of the uyghur
muslims being loaded into trains
headshaven all that's happening and it
sounds like
if trump isn't the president in the next
four years we will just to be subjects
of china
i mean i don't think we'll be subjects
of china i think that we're too
strong figuratively but like it'll get
to the point where literally
whatever soft power we had i mean like
it just it will be gone right like we'll
ask someone we're
we're we're a generation or two out you
know you see what tick tock is doing
people don't realize this without how
tic tac works
um you know what i'm gonna stop and talk
about a different social media app
okay that's similar and what they do is
and i've mentioned this before
you get in order to get a bunch of young
people using your social media app so
you can manipulate them and control what
they see and what they think
you you get some kids to use it you give
them fake followers
all of a sudden some high school kids
like i got 2 000 followers on this app
like i don't i don't have any followers
on facebook or twitter they use the app
more they get more followers the
followers aren't real
they brag to their friends you got how
many followers do you have 50
i got 4 000 on tick tock or i should say
a different app not not tic tac no i
mean literally different yeah
uh because i don't know if tic-tac did
this but i know there's another company
that
did this and it worked out very very
very very well for them
you get all these young people to use it
and eventually you've created a cultural
wave that everybody wants to be on it
because they want to get recognition
they want the followers they want the
points they want the score
then you use the algorithm to control
what they can see and what they can't
see
all of a sudden now anything negative
about china is gone everything positive
about china's coming back
donald trump is the orange man he's
awful he's evil he's bad everybody hates
him right you better go vote
then you get a big surge of young people
who go out and vote and that's
manipulated
through the technology coming from these
other countries it's fifth generational
warfare i mean there's a reason china
doesn't let its citizens use twitter
exactly but they use it they use it on
our for us yeah like i mean
there needs to be reciprocity there or
nothing at all right like and we should
be i mean
it's ridiculous that it took so long or
that people were even pushing back
against the problem of chinese
and they're aggressively going after
vpns so people in china can't even
you know change their addresses to see
what people in the world are saying so
just imagine living in china where your
social credit score relies on what you
regurgitate what you read if you read
something you're not supposed to read
your social credit score goes down and
this is a society
that other places like singapore and
other governments are even
thinking about adapting themselves
because this is a great way to control
people
to subjugate people and to benefit the
special interest class
which are seeing these things they're
saying wait this could be probably good
here and then we have
a biden administration where his cabinet
is being filled with individuals that
are literally arguing
we can't do anything to stifle we
shouldn't stop china because if we do
that's going to hurt the global economy
we need to let china rise
and these are key individuals that are
going to be in biden's administration
very soon just lay down and put your
hands up and expose your soft underbelly
for china that's why we they just want
to lock up the uyghur muslims we need
satellite internet
uh we need to bypass isps and get this
free software mesh network in place
we need it here because so we don't get
censored but they need it
yeah i mean free and open internet is
something critically important and when
you see china controlling it
controlling what their people can and
cannot listen to and see
this is a huge vast power that it just
started out with saying
with the government coming out saying no
we're going to tell you what you should
listen to
we know what's best for you just like
corporations are making the argument
here
we have to fight against fake news and
everything that's wrong in our society
we're going to curate everything for you
and provide it to you on a silver
platter i think we're on track to
based on everything we're seeing
happening right now when i say that
we'll be subjects of
of china i don't mean in a year i mean
in 50
or 100. we will be a weak
old regional power probably fractured in
many ways with a you know disparate
broken government
and some i imagine at that point you
know and again a lot of variables from
now between the 50 or 100 years
but uh china's got the power china's
growing china is controlling
us and we're losing
i don't know i'm i would say i'm that as
pessimistic as you are but i definitely
think that we're in general i mean the
democrats are
you know continued democrat control will
lead to that sure look at look at the
past several decades of what the us has
been doing sending our manufacturing
overseas trans-pacific partnership
now you know joe biden's going to jump
in whatever pacific partnership
agreement there's going to be
and it's not just about china they're
they're they're the biggest threat the
u.s has right now but it's also about
the u.s just giving up
and it's not like the collective spirit
of america has said oh i failed i'm done
it's that we've got politicians that
never cared about us
and it's partly our fault when people go
and they say i'm a vote democrat i'm
voting republican they don't know who
they're voting for
they end up voting for people who are
just like vote for me and you know i'll
fight for you i'll give you whatever you
want and then all they really wanted was
the keys to the castle
they want to get the paycheck they want
to get the pension and they want to get
their name etched in stone for history
and then they did nothing and then when
it came to passing bills they said
how much money can we make in the short
term if we send our manufacturing to you
know to mexico to indonesia to
you know to uh vietnam or china we'll
make a ton of money in the short term
what about the long term oh we'll lose
yeah but we won't care about that that's
our kids right
politicians have sold out the next
generations and so surprised to me
you've got so many young people who are
becoming socialists
that seems to me like the downward
trajectory is
we had a period where a bunch of our
leaders were selling at a manufacturing
base
for a short-term gain with a long-term
loss
and then we created this world where
these kids are like well just go to
college then right
that's the solution there's no more good
manufacturing jobs go to college
and you'll get a good paying job but
what happens when everybody has a degree
in some field or another and you're
competing with people on the same level
once again there are still no jobs
there can be a million good computer
jobs but if
you know 50 million kids are coming out
of college with computer degrees there's
still no jobs
now they're saying nothing works we need
communism but communism doesn't produce
anything
it extracts things so over a long enough
period of time
as everyone keeps demanding the
government pay my bills we need a
stimulus lock everything down have the
government pay for it
the government can print money money can
facilitate trade but if there's nothing
being produced
there's nothing to trade in the long run
yeah i think that's right all right i
need to quickly use a restaurant if
that's yeah i'll do it
i just did that i would say all the jobs
are definitely
in china with the uyghur muslims
producing a lot of the corporate
american goods that lecture us
on racism here in the united states
which is something that people need to
realize as well but
i don't know if we want to go into the
next story but i mean they infiltrate
not only these kind of intellectual
institutions that kind of set
uh our young children to be where they
are right now
china has a huge influence on the
universities and colleges but
they also infiltrate politicians in more
ways than one as well
what are you getting today with the
chinese spy
oh that's right
has the nerve to say cheat an election
yes when he had a fundraiser organized
by a chinese spy
yes and there's accusations by donald
trump jr that allegedly this spy had
relations with mr eric swalwell which by
the way
eric swalwall was one of the biggest
proponents of russian collusion if you
remember he was
out there on all the media networks they
loved him he was ranting and raving
there's a foreign government
infiltrating our government there's a
foreign government controlling
everything luke the russians are
colluding he fights and he farted
on tv while accusing the very arc of
trying to cheat an election exactly
and at the same time he was being
infiltrated at very high levels
by a chinese government which he had
very close
dealings with now this person is very
interesting because
they they are describing her as a
honeypot she slept with many prominent
government officials
and she escaped to china as soon as the
fbi came looking for her they saw that
she somehow miraculously
escaped which is absolutely juggling so
the biden family is compromised
dianne feinstein had a chinese spy
working for office and now swalwell and
many other people had a spy working
forum
secretary pompeo said that chinese
governments infiltrated every level of
government
not just not just infiltrated i mean
this spy was deemed
an important political figure in
california she was orchestrating a lot
of the campaigns a lot of the
fundraisers raising for swallowing
exactly so there's individuals right now
saying suawell needs to resign
immediately since he's been infiltrated
the mainstream media right now is
is slowly patting him on the back saying
it's okay he's a victim here
he was given a briefing by the fbi they
didn't do that for trump
yep when when trump was accused of
russia they just started spying on the
fbi called him and notified him that he
was
infiltrated by the chinese government
and we still don't know exactly what
this person has we don't know what
information they were able to gather
this person also did fundraisers for
tulsi gabbard of all people
wow yes so this is a major big story
that's going to have a lot of
ramifications because when you look at
the beijing professor he also
talked about a political figure that
helped him out
tremendously that now has chinese
citizens and that was back in china so
we saw this beijing professor literally
talk about this
gloating about this acting very happy
that this happened
and now we have this story that just
came out there and uh i think this
probably happened
a couple weeks ago maybe even a couple
of months ago and now we're just finding
out about it because there's a
correlation with it
you just make me more pessimistic about
the whole china thing well i mean i
rather
know the truth and reality that we're
facing then be blind to exactly what's
going on because we have to understand
our institutions are corrupted
to the core and they need to be replaced
immediately listen listen
if you just praise the glory that is the
chinese communist party then you'll get
to be
a wealthy party member you'll have a
nice
loft top the tallest building i wouldn't
just feel right
you know imprisoning the leaders i i
wouldn't feel right in prisoning the
poor
people would would you rather go to the
gulag yourself all you have to do is
give in
no thank you that's what's happening
though
it's it's it's the way people feel it's
a path of least resistance
why bother fighting against this machine
that is that is
you know gaining strength and taking
over when you can just give in and be
rich
right i mean that's how they went over
the elites so
yeah well we're talking about the spying
program that was revealed
today with the chinese honey pot that's
infiltrated more ways than one a lot of
us government officials
what do you think about that because a
lot of people are saying this is
room for swalwell to resign like swallow
or redesign uh do you think that's
legitimate do you think there's any
legal merit in that
i mean there's there's not a legal it's
not a legal argument it's a political
argument
i think you should resign i think this
should be looked at like i think you
should have resigned a long time ago
like you you had a
you were compromised by a russian spy in
the middle of the cold war yeah
time for you to resign yeah like in you
know i mean but i'm in general think
a lot more people in our government
should be resigning i think they should
all resign
and term like separate and retiring from
public life like why hasn't bill crystal
retired from public oh seriously
or henry kissinger of all people yeah he
got fired by trump
his organization did he's 90 doesn't he
have grandchildren he can hang out with
him it's fine
is it doesn't it seem like trump is i'll
say this in my opinion trump is doing
everything he's doing he's acting as
though he's not going anywhere
i mean i think that's it i think it's a
front honestly i think he'll
you know remember that he was a
billionaire and he gave up the life of
the billionaire and he'll be returning
to the life of a billionaire for the
most part
um yeah but i don't know the the the the
tds individuals are gonna go after him
like the state yeah
right prosecutors um there's a bunch of
them they're nuts
like we're like that's what i'm saying
man i i i can't imagine
everything just goes back to normal the
way some of these people like these
democrat voters think is gonna happen
because yeah they're like the calls for
unity like i'm sorry like you don't get
to call us nazis one day and then
suddenly have me turn around and sing
kumbaya with you but they think it's
going to calm down when you've literally
got
you know linwood and cindy powell for
instance saying don't vote republican
oh my gosh i mean that said like and
there's stuff like i'm seeing like calls
for martial law
and um you know like i i'm not for any
of that like
in that respect i'm just like count me
out like i'm not going to sit here and
well
we got to be honest here if the
republicans were accused of stealing the
election
i think half of america would be burned
down by now oh yeah sure right like that
i mean
but you know that that's also like the
consequence of that like if
what you're calling for is like martial
law and a re-vote the con
and if you actually prevailed then half
of america would be burned down
if trump succeeds in his efforts
and you know because president yeah it's
going to be anti-fun times 10 times
and i mean like i i mean that's not
that's not independently a reason right
the question is
like i i the reason i oppose that is not
like oh well antifa is bad and they'll
do bad things it's not
you know we shouldn't let that control
our behavior and decision making but
uh that doesn't mean i ever i want to
live in a country with cous
or uh sort of what do you what do you
what look if if trump on january 21st
is a regular guy again the new new
york's going after him like crazy
and and the media smears and lies about
him it's intense
i don't know i mean it's just you you
remember everybody hated nixon and then
they stopped and they forgot after the
forward pardon i i could even see a
biden pardon of trump honestly
that's federal level what about the
state the state legislation part of the
state level but i think
i think the the sort of urgency and onus
to keep going after trump is gone if
he's not president anymore
i think perhaps that's my i mean i might
be wrong but i don't i don't think so
though because i think they need their
boogeyman they need their villain
and and and you know the articles that
are coming out right now from the left
say
in order for us to heal trump must go to
prison
yeah no a lot of a lot of hot takes come
from the left on that well they've been
calling for things like truth and
reconciliation commissions
tribunals tribunals so like so he's like
hideki tojo
i'll say i'll say a couple things you
wanna you know uh you
by all means call out the people saying
we need martial law right yeah the
democrats have already implemented it in
many states
oh you know over covered right and then
you add that to the fact now they're
saying tribunals
for not just trump but his enablers and
some people have gone so far as they put
a list of their supporters
so that would be you me or or even luke
even though luke's not a trump supporter
it doesn't matter
you've called out china you've been
critical of the left therefore it's good
enough for them
ian who's actually kind of a hippie dude
they'd say doesn't matter he's on the
team cast irl show put them on the list
of enablers and supporters
so if if we're at the point where we
already have
martial law locked in many places in
states that's violating the constitution
they're calling for truth and
reconciliation commissions tribunals
and things like that and then on the
other side they're calling for martial
law
like how does this come go go down
i mean i don't know how it resolves i
think you know my hope
is collapse
right like if you're making predictions
i don't know i mean i i think
and there's a lot of other you know i
mean the covet reorientation of wealth
to
the big companies versus people people
having nothing left are going to snap
like that viral video of the pineapple
uh hill woman
where she's got this outdoor seating
area that newsom's like you can't you
can't use it and then right next to it
is hollywood food production services
totally fine regular people are looking
at that their brains are going to
explode
yeah and i i wonder if the consequences
for that are finally going to be felt in
a world where trump isn't around
like he's just he does have this effect
of like sucking all the air out of the
room and that in terms of media coverage
i mean the thing about it's it is really
deeply offensive that gavin you know
these
politicians can't adhere to their own
guidelines and they don't want to
it's also important to note that we saw
record levels of protest under the
uh obama administration when he first
came in we saw occupy wall street
so that's also another factor to really
consider here and also that a big swap
of the left is not really impressed with
biden at all
but i was going to ask you how do you
see this unfolding in the worst case
scenario
and how you see it unfolding in the best
case scenario i mean
worst case you get i mean i guess like
democrats are going to be in control the
federal government and republicans
generally don't do
like full-scale rebellion right and they
don't do cultural institutions
and they don't do cultural institutions
but they also don't do like antifa type
stuff in general like there isn't you
know you don't see the sort of burning
down of the cities and
so how would you let me let me know your
thoughts on this i think we might see
you know joe biden for instance he wants
to ban all online sales of guns and
accessories and ammo and things like
that
he wants to do what what you bullet
registration and the two hundred dollar
tax on
everything every gun nfl any yeah what
does national firearms act is out of
this or yes yes well
so that's why we need to make sure we
don't lose the damn senate
well so so what happens then if if he
does this if the senate does this if
they pack the courts
i wouldn't be surprised if a bunch of
jurisdictions small towns all of a
sudden had right-wing militias
i mean i think that that would be a
point where you'd actually see the sort
of rebellions that
you and like you know real serious
anti-government activity that's sort of
hinted at in the 90s under clinton
uh but that might become like a really
big and that's why we had the uh
what was it like what were the two you
had waco ruby right ruby ridge
yeah but i think i mean my guess is
that's ultimately going to be just talk
i don't think biden's going to sign new
gun legislation i think that i mean
democrats you don't think they'll pack
the supreme court i mean if i think
i think if they had the power they would
do it um and i think the the big problem
there
is what you'll what though i think i
don't know if biden will do that stuff
at the federal level but what i expect
will be
um in a world where the court is packed
dc versus heller gets overturned the
what is that one that's the court
decision that establishes that the right
to bear arms is an individual right and
not a collective one
so right so the collective right would
be like if there's a militia then you're
allowed to be in the military with guns
exactly um and it's scary that that
decision is even close like that i mean
that it requires real bastardization of
the grammar of the second
have you read the original second
amendment no the one that says why don't
we do whatever we want with guns
it's like it's like that uh parks and
rec ron swanson like
this is when when they were initially
proposing the bill of rights there were
like 17 articles that were proposed
the original second amendment said
something to the effect of
if someone chooses not to join active
duty militia or military they that they
will still have the right to bear arms
and they took that language out i guess
because there was a concern about
it could potentially mean people could
you could avoid conscription
so initially they were like you can bear
you know a well-regulated militia being
necessary to you know for a free state
the right to bear arms should not be
infringed and if an individual chooses
not to join
or be part of militia they shall still
have the right to bear arms and they
were like wait wait get rid of that part
because it makes it sound
like you can avoid conscription and we
need conscription because at the time
if you were an able-bodied male it's
like you're going to war buddy
so they get rid of it now we have these
arguments which i think
are completely in bad faith if you
actually look at the history of the
second amendment we had privateers we
had corsairs
like regular a regular dude's like
here's my battleship i can use to blow
up a french you know
trade vessel regular citizens had
cannons on their houses and properties
and things like that so they could
now now it's like you can't have any of
that
and that's the argument but but also
defund the police because the police are
bad and and really just like let
yourself be at the mercy of people
that's why i think what we're talking
about is fifth generational warfare
disarm the people and disarm their their
local police
why would you do that let me tell you
this in these west coast places where
they're very prominently doing this
portland seattle places in california
it's already hard enough to get a gun in
california
now you've got defund the police what do
you think would happen if you had
northern california
nobody's armed well northern california
is fairly republican so people got a lot
probably have long guns but let's say
you have a city very few people have
guns
and the police are now defunded and
fractured
anybody can walk right in just dystopian
i've you know i'm from california i
would never move back
and it's it's sad to see what's happened
to the state i think
if you know they get the senate and i do
think they'll get it i do
because trump's not on the ticket look
at 2018 they didn't have
the the the uh with trump supporters are
not republicans
for the most part yeah but stacey abram
lost in 16 she lost to brian kemp
and 16. yeah i'm sorry that's true um
i mean and like i still you know i still
want to
george has a red state in general i
think it just had a particular coalition
sort of like utah if like utah were a
closer state utah was you know very
mormon and
and had a big chunk of you know
trump underperformed his normal the
normal republican performance in that
state so i think george is kind of
similar in that respect where you've got
you know that big suburban atlanta
population
since you're a betting man what odds
would you give on georgia going
republican
going republican i'd say i mean 70
chance 75
chance wow i think that's what the the
batting odds are right now it's like 70
70 something sounds about right to me
right like you know when i was the funny
thing is i didn't bet on the origin of
the election
before the election because i thought
the odds were about right you know i
think trump was about a two to one dog
or something like that and i thought
that was right i have to say either way
it doesn't look
good because if you know the senate is
by one a majority of the republicans how
much dirt do the chinese have especially
with their honey pots on one politician
to persuade them or to push them and to
do whatever they want i mean and they've
been doing some crazy stuff i mean they
decided
i still don't understand this and why
they would even consider it they did the
mike lee's immigration bill where he
wanted to like remove country caps like
guys you get a grip we're trying to win
the senate here and you're out there
you're you're pushing liberalized
immigration policy when there's a
republic
that's why i i i don't even think the
republicans are going to do enough to uh
defend the country i just i mean i don't
want to be launched out of them i just
expect them not to do things that are
all you know disastrous and catastrophic
because i mean
the way i look at it is democrats want
to completely remove the ability for
republicans to win elections
if you i don't know if you've read the
book it's time to fight dirty i might
have recommended it i don't know
but basically i mean what do they want
to do why they want to do it pack the
supreme court
add more states they can't control the
senate permanently uh
you know national voter you know
automatic voter registration
hall voting day a holiday they want to
complete universal mail in voting
university and the argument is we want
to make all of it we make it easier for
people to vote and
that's that's just not true yeah they're
trying to strip away election security
that's what they're doing
yeah and i mean but the end goal here is
permanent democratic control they
thought they almost had it they thought
they were going to get it
one of the you know and that's actually
one of the arguments like why i don't
think the whole thing was
rigged you know in terms of like well
the voting machines are rigged well if
the voting
machines were rigged why didn't they
just get a result in line with polling
you know democrats underperformed public
polling in the run-up to the election
they could have
joe well yeah the polling was nuts
though
it was sure insane but like look if you
want to play
it's easily explained in terms of the
you know the the the trump supporter can
more conspiracy mindset
the polls were propaganda to demoralize
voters
saying trump's going to win don't bother
sure i agree then when it came to
actually
as trump has said this is their opinion
that he ended up winning
so well that they panicked and had to
really go crazy on you know cranking out
the fake votes just so story you know
everything right well as i'm saying this
there's like that there is an
explanation
the left is saying right now if biden
cheated then how come he the democrats
lost down ballot
well because there's a bunch of uh
undervotes votes that were just for
biden
right i mean and like i think there's
plenty of cheating on the fringe
right like i still think that you know i
watched poll watchers get denied entry i
watched how
frivolous like the behavior of these
democratic poll workers was and i'm like
these people could have
there's no moral thing that would have
stopped these people from doing some
amount of cheating if they could get
away with it
um the question is just what could they
get away with and i think
you know you end up getting away with
things like coheirs
absentee votes duplicate votes those
sort of
and then maybe some well they were in
philly they were putting up those signs
saying here's who you should vote for
yeah like that's like it's the weird
like it's like the cheating on the
margins or fraud in the margins versus
like fraud at the core
and i think that i haven't seen any good
evidence of fraud at the core i don't
think there's like proof of
you know these the the dominion
allegations but there's like yeah that's
that's the so wait
you know you know what really bothered
me about the dominion stuff is that i i
even said this on the show i got really
mad about it
because the dominion stuff and and
hammer and scorecard
was a red herring it was it was
here's what happens there will be some
dirty politician
and they'll get caught doing something
illegal and when someone starts sniffing
too close
what they'll do is they'll throw out
some crazy idea to throw them off the
trail
and then instead of saying i caught this
dude doing drugs it turns into crazy
pizza cult at you know
in dc and now the real crime is they're
laughing
saying we trick those people how easy so
right now when you've got actual
irregularity and propriety
trump's suing and trying to be
legitimized in his claims
the single worst thing for donald trump
in all of this
was the lawsuit from sydney powell and
the dominion claims
because what trump needed and that's why
a lot of people it's funny they're
claiming that cindy powell is a democrat
lin was a democrat and they're like
trying to subvert trump
i tell you man i was i was reading a
post on reddit
and they said when it comes to a coup
the one thing a a a
leader and and you know the person
staging the coup need is legitimacy
the the current leader needs to tell
everyone i'm in charge i will always be
in charge listen to what i have to say
so that
the lower you know individuals the
police the law enforcement military
listen
what the other guy needs in the coup is
legitimacy
in the same regard here's why i'm
actually in charge listen to me
trump comes out and says 682 thousand
votes
no one was able to observe what's going
on here matthew brainerd's voter
integrity project look at all of these
votes from people who'd live in
different states and voted twice
that's legitimate then all of a sudden
sydney powell comes out with this typo
laden
kraken lawsuit that sounds crazy that
has
you know it's almost impossible to back
up except for a bunch of youtube videos
and a bunch of weird videos popping up
and trump loses that legitimacy the
media jumped on that in two seconds
and tried making every claim from the
trump campaign about the fringes and
craziest conspiracy
to delegitimize his claim that he
actually won
and it worked yep yeah no i those
lawsuits are
a disaster they were i mean like and and
i had people in my mentions constantly
who knows if they're real or not
honestly but like people and i mentioned
being like how dare you say that this
won't work
and it's just like because i'm a lawyer
and i can these people are relief
the people are real i've i've know i
know people in my life i've talked to
people who are adamantly convinced the
dominion stuff is real i'll tell you
what maybe
sure but listen voter suppression too
for the georgia thing not to not sorry
interrupt but
right like you're suppressing your own
voters when you tell them that the
election is completely rigged
and you see what happened with ronald
mcdaniel and the lady was asking her
like why should we even bother voting
it's rigged
and she's like no no you have to vote
then you see sydney powell and lynn
wood not only did they delegitimize
trump's claims
strongly not completely they're also now
telling people not to vote for
republicans
i mean it's just you know this is this
is the suicide caucus
like the the sort of we should just
commit electoral suicide because we
didn't get it maybe they're
accelerationists
maybe they are um they think look the
democrats take everything over the
sooner
the fat like here's the problem frogs
boiling in a pot
eventually just boil but you throw
boiling water water at a frog and the
frog is going to jump and run away
maybe that's what the accelerationists
think yeah yeah
i mean well maybe that's maybe that's
there's some big giant strategy but
really i think it's just a giant pr
exercise from people who've gotten high
on their own supply of pr but what about
trump do you think trump's trying to win
though
i mean i think he's trying to win i just
think i think he's you know he's been a
businessman for a long time he's a guy
who's litigated a bunch of cases
to the end so he's probably just like
he's doing what he does he's like any
other businessman he'll litigate hard as
long as he can until his appeals are
exhausted and then he'll comply that's
what i think all right let's do this
uh we would normally now jump to super
chats but i want to do one more segment
because i've been sitting on the story
and it's a week old now but i really
want to talk about it
it has very little to do with politics
and everything to do with just the
absurdity of the modern
political world ladies and gentlemen
vanderbilt players were crying
during sarah fuller's 30-yard kick this
is an
actual news story let me break it down
for you sarah fuller
is the first woman to play and what is
it power five i think it's called
i'm not a big football fan so i don't
know a whole lot about what this means
changing the game
sarah fuller became the first woman to
play in a power five college football
game
the team she's on vanderbilt lost 41-0
she came out in the second half and did
uh she kicked and
kicked like between 20 and 30 yards and
then they ended up losing
i tweeted about this and i didn't say
anything negative because i was just
like i was like his history was made
for the uh you know the first woman to
to play in a power five game
loses 41 to zero she kicked 30 yards and
people were trying to convince me like
say to me
she she was it was a squib kick it was
on purpose
right then we got then we got more news
this is the craziest thing
vanderbilt players consider opting out a
final game at georgia
another kicker joining team after this
fiasco
players actually said that they wouldn't
play
in another game they were not going to
do it seems like
i don't know if this team thought hey
we'll just put the first female kick
around to get all this good social
justice pr
but it resulted in the players actually
crying so this is the story from the
daily caller they say
vanderbilt players were apparently
emotional during sarah fuller's kick
against missouri okay
maybe they were crying because with
tears of joy right they were just crying
watching this historic moment
sure during the 41-0 blowout loss
fuller became the first woman to play in
a major college football game
when she kicked the start of the second
half the ball went a staggering 30 yards
there were some people on the sideline
tearing up quarterback mike wright said
during a game
during during a saturday morning college
game day segment on fuller's kick
as hard as that might be to believe i
can promise that i'm not making this up
you can watch the video below
it used to be an insult yadda yadda when
is this nonsense going to end they say
this is nothing more than a pr stunt
which didn't save derek mason's job
and now we're out here talking about
players crying are you kidding me
this can't possibly be real from the way
people talk about fuller's kick
you'd think she was the first woman to
walk on the moon so it sounds like
they're actually saying they were crying
tears of joy
right yeah i mean it's it's incredibly
silly
and patronizing yes and i mean
any meaningful i don't know i mean
there's record low testosterone out
there
and it keeps going down remember the try
guys from buzzfeed yes another segment
so so there were four guys at buzzfeed
and they got their t levels tested
and they were all like 80 year old men i
could have told you that just looking at
them though
super low and it's kind of it's kind of
crazy i wonder is there like
what's going on there's been a
progressive decline in testosterone
that's been tested
throughout the decades there's many
theories out there there's many
different explanations some people are
talking about microplastics some people
are talking about poor diet some people
are talking about
birth control in the water birth control
in the water which is another thing some
people are talking about the frogs
deciding to change their orientation
turn the freaking frog
i didn't want to say that but yeah
exactly what's been happening so there's
many different is that going to de-rank
you i don't know maybe i don't know
they're gonna think it was actually alex
jones they're gonna be like we caught it
somebody just like no no i'm just doing
it in person but this is a serious issue
because reproductivity of human beings
is going down dramatically so people
uh well so what does that have to do
with the kick in the well we just made a
comment about the testosterone issue and
maybe they were crying for real
because they no i feel emotional when i
read that i thought they were crying
because like their careers are now
destroyed
yeah they're now losers on a losing team
because of this pr stunt
woman they lost forty one two three
maybe you're not familiar with this like
there was a
some chicago white sox owner who had his
team
like send out a six-year-old or
something to bat in the baseball game
really he walked because the small
strike zone
is that real that's real like look at
that i think it's eddie geidell
g-a-e-d-e-l
i think that's right but like i know the
owner is bill beck see if i can see if i
got the name right
that's amazing i always find that things
like eddie
look at that man my memory is good he
was he was uh the world's smallest
player
he was five foot six inches no no that's
rizzuto click on the click on the link
oh this eddie guy dell
yeah there you go look at that that's
real
that happened oh wow but he wasn't six
years old i'm not sure how old he was
when he played he's just a little person
no no he was a child he was a child he
was a child he gained recognition
in the second game of the st louis
brown's double header weighing 60
pounds and saying it three foot seven
inches he became the shortest player in
history of the major leagues oh no
you're right i guess i guess you're
right he was
actually he was a child yeah smart play
though
smart player tiny strike zone hard to
hard to get that he's gonna in he walks
yeah he walks uh so okay so that's what
i didn't remember quickly so
what is the strategic advantage of
having a female kicker there there isn't
one but i
guess that's not buzzfeed's gonna like
you i was i was thinking it's like you
know 50 years ago people recognize this
sort of thing as like a ridiculous stun
and it's like well i'm going to tell you
i'm going to tell you the reason i want
to talk about this is because i said
i think like three years ago when like a
lot of video game and movie stuff was
happening
i said it's only a matter of time before
they just change the rules to mandate
women in major league sports
like why not the rules are arbitrary
right we could we could we could raise
the basketball uh uh nets five feet
we just agree to do it no more dunking
or something right people might still be
able to dunk i guess
but we could just say okay new world
changed so what if right now everyone
just said okay new rule change
players have to be half women half men
why not
well um is the nba gonna be diverse
then you just see a bunch of i mean
there would be a huge market
for uh trans women well i i said back
then
it's only a matter of time before there
are diversity demands
in major league sports if the rules can
be changed by people
then there's no reason they can't have a
rule saying the easiest way to get women
in major league sports
is just to mandate that they're there
it's it's the same as any diversity
quota
it's not about your your merit it's
about making sure there's representation
in the game right
i mean you know i would have i would
have said democrats wouldn't do that but
they've done a lot of crazy things in
the past few years but this already
happens in mainstream society in the
corporate world this
already exists so why wouldn't it exist
in the mba
and and i think it's going to it's
absolutely going to do they'll get their
bones broken
well perhaps or perhaps you're a bigot
ian no
theology you gotta be you gotta be this
existence every
compassion will can you hear this bigot
everyone knows there's no difference
at all struck by the fact that he's not
recognizing the impact of discourse on
physiology
yeah we can talk people to be the same
that's right well no no but think about
this think about this the the
there's no rule stopping women from
playing in any major league sport
they just don't ever win when they try
out they like you know she kicked 30
yards
she didn't kick 70. i was so i looked up
i don't know anything about football and
they said a good a good you know kick is
70 yards
she might have been kicking on side
because they're down so far was that the
case
well down
and some people said it was a squib kick
intentionally which is an on-site yeah
yeah
she might be a great kicker yeah for a
woman but so
the point is look we make up the rules
of the game
right now the rules are the best of the
best are chosen by the managers and the
and on the owners for who's going to be
on the team we could simply just say
yeah exactly
so diversity over meritocracy as men are
losing testosterone are women getting
more beastly
i don't know well i don't know about
naturally like men are naturally losing
testosterone yeah like
the buzzfeed guys are a good example of
that but i think that might be because
they're not exercising
yeah it's really you know look guys used
to have to go and chop lumber
true now they sit at their desks and eat
doritos and drink mountain dew
you know it was not good for my
waistline that's fine
nobody's but uh uh maybe maybe with more
women getting in
in sports and things like that maybe
we'll see an increase over time but uh
look the point i'm saying is
you you mentioned in corporations we
already have the diversity quotas you
look at california now they passed that
law where they got to
where yeah mandatory board member must
be like female or
you know you know minority or whatever
why not in major league sports
and i'm not saying i'm not saying why
not in the sense of i'm advocating for
it i'm saying
why wouldn't they do it they will be
having it and you're calling it out and
we're going to see in a few months maybe
you know even a few years just these
kind of people
rising representation of here we are
it's like
all these people are all the same
everyone gets an award i don't know i
mean you might end up
it just it might be a bridge too far
right like you you get the sense that
people were able to do a lot of things
like i want you think about this like i
wonder how long the mass kneeling would
have lasted in a world where
the crowds were still at the arenas
right after george floyd
there's a sense where they could get
away with it because there was no
audience to boo i wonder how long people
would do that if there was systematic
booing well look what happened to the
nba in their record low ratings with
them politicizing this and literally
putting black lives matter on the
basketball court
and then they polled people it was a
hill harris x and they found that
most people said i can't stand the
politics yeah so they're not watching
anymore
well i watched one game and it was just
during the timeouts during the
interviews
any kind of patronizing any kind of
virtual signal they could put out they
put out there as much as they could so
what you're saying i think is going to
come true it's only going to be a matter
of time
and uh it's trendy it's cool will you
got to get with the times
yeah that's why i'm a conservative
[Laughter]
it's gonna come down to uh clapter
right what we're gonna see is people are
gonna be watching sports and they're not
gonna care about touchdowns or
scores they're gonna care about
representation of people so
it's like that episode of south park
where they had sarcastical where
football was too rough so then it turned
into a game of tag and then it was like
them chasing balloons around and
wearing bras and it was because randy
was like okay
fine like it's too rough why don't we
just have the kids chase balloons
instead i guess
and they're like okay that's a good idea
oh okay then why not have them wear bras
while they do it and they're like
okay let's do it and they did it and the
game became just ridiculous nonsense
and then they didn't realize like they
were like i don't know if i'm being
sarcastic anymore nothing makes sense
everything's broken but i think i think
that's where we're going we're going to
get to
we're going to start seeing a bunch of
these you know political if
you did if you had like a force-fed men
and women
on this football field together you'd
eventually get like a group of rogue
dudes that are huge and beast
that would just go start their own
league i think you know you know what i
i i was reading that we should just let
everybody take whatever drugs they want
in terms of performing enhancements just
kidding and just who joe rogan talking
about this summer
probably where they were like just let
everybody take whatever drugs they want
and then you'll have gigantic monsters
just running on the fields like steroids
yeah just everything just
you know their heart rate's like 250
resting and they're like
running you know 30 miles an hour just
just the craziest
all out barry bonds was roided out a lot
of people
seriously steroid it out and they did we
just didn't know about it yeah
so let's roll it okay let's do super
chats yes super chats
all right uh if you haven't already
smash the like button
hit the notification bell subscribe uh
we do the show monday friday live at 8
pm but let's
read what y'all have to say bill ray
says louisiana just joined texas lawsuit
with scotus more states that said to
follow is that can you google yes i saw
that
that's true out there as well it's true
don't think it'll matter uh
sorry really to be like the black pill
on this but it's really going to be a
question stop raining on our parade will
i know
except your corporate chinese overlords
i mean the question from the supreme
court's perspective
is not how many states agree that we
should sue here but like do we want
i mean think about from their
perspective right now there are election
contests in states and this litigation
is handled elsewhere do they really want
to be
the court of first resort for any first
upset about election results
what if what if what if they have
secretly their own self preservation at
heart
they know that the court will get packed
and they'll lose all their legitimacy i
mean become a legislative body and then
eventually they'll say we vote for the
supreme court justices
i i just don't think they're i you know
i'd like i've been around a little long
enough to be
see when when the supreme court decides
they don't want to hear cases and they
don't have to
they end up not i mean that said i mean
i could be wrong here because there's
three
justices who might end up agreeing with
alito and thomas um that we haven't
heard from on the issue of whether or
not they think it's actually mandatory
for them to take these cases
leading thomas do think it's mandatory
yeah leto and thomas think it's
mandatory
but for a long time the majority has
said it's discretionary and i mean
that's that's a practice so you would
you
say thomas if potentially kavanaugh and
amy coney barrett
and you always need yeah so potentially
gorsuch possible i just
just doubtful the three we don't know
their opinions and if they do agree
yeah but i mean if they if they agree
there's a lot of reasons for them to not
want to agree because
you know they've they've just invited a
whole bunch but come on come on come on
will
don't you think that clarence thomas has
waited 30 years for his revenge against
joe biden that's the
that's the meaning i mean i bet he i bet
he is very tempted
i bet he is no you know what you know
that meme where you've seen the meme
where clarence thomas's eyes are glowing
and it says i've been waiting 30 years
for this moment mr body
whatever right i i was like i think
clarence thomas
is of sound mind and integrity and
maturity that he would not
have that he he he these these are
some of the most you know people of
highest integrity and and merit
i don't see them being like i have a
personal grudge to fulfill and i've been
waiting 30 years and i'm going to use
the court to get it that doesn't sound
like it's not that's not how it works
that's not how they want to do their
jobs
um maybe though i mean i i saw that look
on kavanaugh's face
and remember what he said like he like
said what did he say something about
you know them getting what they deserve
or something like that yeah i mean
like i and it's kamala harris yeah and
she knows
but i mean there's there's just an ethos
to judging that a lot of these judges
have which is they won't they take pride
in applying the law as written
and doing it better than other people
and in a more fair way it's almost like
law is kind of it's almost like a kind
of game or puzzle that you're trying to
like
you know in the in the legal problems or
puzzles you're trying to elegantly solve
and
it's hard to escape from that to do
something so radical william martinez
says according to trump lawyer john
ellis it isn't rejected they only
rejected the emergency injunction relief
right we we talked about that basically
the idea is
if they don't put uh if they don't agree
with the injunction now
then what relief could they possibly
give if the lawsuit can't
do anything there's a reason they they
filed the emergency injunctive relief
it's important
um the fact that you had unanimous
denial of that without a dissent
is a real i mean it's just a really bad
side for the underlying litigation
um you know and and i think that in a
world where they really did think that
uh the pennsylvania plaintiffs would
they would be inclined to grant that
relief
so these are super chats from a while
ago ziggy says lawsuit was dismissed
because of texas lawsuit also seven more
states just joined texas
i haven't seen seven yeah i haven't seen
seven i have okay
i have seen arkansas alabama and
louisiana who are supporting texas this
is from three hours ago
really yeah i don't know there might be
even more
are we gonna get the second civil war
here that's the most recent thing i saw
people i i think again
just not to put cold water on it i feel
like i'm a
but it's like the idea that the the
supreme court would dismiss one case
in order because texas filed a lawsuit
that is a type of lawsuit that is very
narrowly circumscribed to these like
water rights type cases
a lot of people are saying seven other
states just joined let me see what else
i can find
yeah i just i'm i am not optimistic
that's that again like i i do say that
i'm more optimistic about this than i
have been about other things just
because
instead of having like six or seven
independent procedural bars to hearing
the case there's just this one
thing and so if the core gets over this
one thing they'll prob they'll
they could hear it um i think you're
just a negative nancy will
and you just hate trump i'm i'm so tired
of being
everybody's everybody's like maybe i
should just put my brain in a bowl of
warm water and forget
weeks well no it is funny though because
it's like when i'm reading legal
analysis on twitter
the right-wing opinions are always like
here's why trump is going to win and the
left is always why this is what trump's
going to lose
yeah and then they there's a tendency so
far for
trump only had a few lawsuits and then
you had a bunch of other lawsuits from
other people the left
you know these leftist legal opinions
are always like oh that's trump down 40
now and it's like trump didn't actually
file all those lawsuits like he can't
control those people so they're really
trying to ham it up
but then in certain you know you get the
point right
yeah and i mean you know you can't help
like when somebody files a lawsuit
that's terrible
and it gets thrown out on jurisdictional
grounds yep
mike uh i almost read it i almost read
it gonna get me in trouble
mr hunt first name mike says watch
viva phrase video on the texas lawsuit
we will win
well i don't know viva fray he's he's
yeah but i i think like you know i tried
to do my reading on this and like when i
first read the law
well it will just put that put that
negative feeling in the back of your
mind
and lie so you can get more followers on
twitter
yes does that work yes of course it does
that's what tutor is
yeah come on man all you guys if you
came out and said
hi i'm a respectable lawyer and i run a
publication and my clearly legal
analysis suggests that donald trump is
guaranteed victory you'd gain a bunch of
followers
i'd probably get like ten thousand
retweets our meet dylan
tweeted out from you know lynn woods
said that raffensberger and camp are
going to prison or whatever and she said
this is bat ass
it's not gonna happen she lost father
and she's like good yeah like if you
want if you want a lawyer to lie to you
go follow them don't follow me
and i'm like exactly exactly like this i
mean that's it's culling the week she's
great yeah absolutely
the commander says a war against china
won't be hopeless
look up bingkov's battleground episodes
of taiwan versus china
the marines are currently training new
missile crews and putting them in ships
in reserve to contain
contain them to the china sea and
counter their island building
interesting yeah they're building
islands yeah floating islands
yep stephen krashevsky says if you want
an example of what scotus will look
like once dems are done with it look at
the pa supreme court political partisan
corrupt
that's correct good good that's a good
chat yeah and then
and then what do we just roll over and
give up now there's no there's no this
this is it right
i mean if they pack the courts and they
give statehood to dc which makes no
sense
puerto rico i can understand and then
all of a sudden republicans never won
elections
and when they and and when they do they
never win any of their votes and it's
extreme
single party rule and then we become
california next thing we know they're
trying to repeal the civil rights act
yeah
because yeah it's too it'll ask for too
much equality yeah
they tried arch uh let's see uh
archimagerius
says in pa if you buy a gun you can
select non-binary for gender on the
application wtf
identify as a fit 145 pound non-binary
with no felonies
yeah you can what people i i have a
random bit on this people seem to
think that everybody said you know
gender is not like
in in the current thing is not a new
it's an it's a new word
you know before 1960s gender only
referred to how it was used in languages
and then the 1960s people realized hey
we want a word that is distinct from
like biological sex to refer to sort of
arc types of behavior among
males and females so let's call it
gender and let's make it that thing
and then 30 years later that's like hey
did you know that gender is a social
construction
i'm like yes that's why it was invented
right but now but now they're saying sex
is a social social construct that's how
they get so i put out a tweet
that was meant to be just like general
support for elliot page
page is female but you know and there
are people who feel a certain way and
ask that you respect them i have i have
no problem giving someone respect when
they've earned it
and i think ellie page is cool so i'm
totally cool with sure i mean there's
also like a basic kind
but here's the thing all saying elliot
page is female
is transphobic and people were like
reporting me like crazy
and quote tweeting saying why won't
twitter ban him why won't twitter venom
because i said a basic fact with respect
the point i was making was that even
though elliot page is a female
elite page is asking for respect and i
think eliot is cool so i'll grant that
respect i have no problem there what's
i think this is great that's fine you
know do your thing the problem is the
left wants you to
think that biological sex is
now a social construct which is not no
it's not so there there is a basic fact
about this but i'm not trying to be mean
like i'm trying to make the point that
we can still respect someone if they if
they you know
you don't you're not guaranteed respect
don't have to give you respect but
people can choose to right there's
there's a difference between
kindness and and mandatory thought
control yep right i think that you know
i'm perfectly happy to be kind and use
people's names the way they want them
used
uh but when you start saying oh we
should mandate pronoun usage i mean
now you're you're mandating how i talk
about you when you're not here
right that's another thing about
pronouns so pronoun i don't when i talk
to you i don't use
your gender or your sex so so a lot of
people are bringing up
jay of legend says seven more states
joined texas louisiana arkansas alabama
florida kentucky mississippi south
carolina south dakota eight states in
total now
but certainly at a certain point there's
a constitutional crisis
right i mean it's just it strikes me as
just like a pr exercise states file
amiku sprees all the time supporting
litigation is that what is that what it
is yeah and i mean it's like that's why
i mean that and so this isn't like an
amicus brief this is like oh well state
apparently under this theory states can
sue other states if they don't enforce
their election laws properly
um i mean it makes sense it makes sense
but then you also kind of see like
shouldn't this be like an amicus brief
in a case where that is not
like straight to the supreme court and
instead you know
there's like election contest procedures
they waited the very last day
for the safe harbor deadline too are
they gonna get the supreme court might
just be like i mean the the there was
one thing i thought that would
the briefing was generally not bad there
were there were a couple things i
noticed one thing and this is more
inside baseball um
the texas solicitor general is not on
the brief and that's not a good story
yeah
people were saying that he wouldn't sign
off on it because he didn't believe in
it yeah i mean that's
this i mean and that's wrong so the
solicitor general of any state is the
person who handles all their appellate
litigation supreme court stuff and the
appellate litigation in their own state
um and they're usually a person who is
like often a supreme court former
supreme court clerk
etc and they're they're in charge of
that and if they're not willing to sign
on it's like
that's not a good sign but i i i'm
saying
after everything we've seen with the
conflict the chaos the fighting the
street battles
the tensions reaching the supreme court
now you have a bunch of states
suing other states whether or not these
states actually mean it
the regular people are seeing this and
trump supporters are agreeing with it
and we're being pushed towards the most
extreme outcome that's true states
lining up against other states that
didn't work out well the first time it
happened five percent of the population
died i don't want that to happen again
i i would argue that it didn't work out
well in that capacity but it actually
worked out very very well
slavery was ended you know i agree that
it's it's a good thing that slavery
ended um
sounds like the most non-controversial
thing i could ever say
i think it was a good thing
that was an idea that was a good idea no
but think about um
the potential outcomes of where we're at
now if it is true
that we are slowly being eroded by um
just feckless politicians who are
selling a sat for you know over a long
time
then regaining control in some capacity
there's a net positive
there's nothing as clearly as moral as
slavery in this instance however
yeah i think the threat of a foreign
power is serious but
civil war you know brought about the end
of slavery i mean that's just
at the end of the day i think like the
other states realize that it's an
obvious pr exercise to like sign on to a
lawsuit that their
constituents want them to sign up right
i understand that but think about what
that means to the regular people of
their state
how many people do you think started
polishing their guns when they heard
eight states are now
supporting the suit yeah no that that's
something to worry about um and probably
and also probably a reason that that
they would deny cert
again right like that they would deny
motion they'd be like we don't want this
we don't want a massive state on state
battle when you're talking about it i
think
i think that's what they would create if
eight states are saying we demand to be
heard and the supreme court says
no then regular people are gonna say are
you kidding me
if eight states can't get listened to in
the federal courts
and we've seen the evidence and they
won't give us the time of day
people are gonna their heads are gonna
explode yeah no that's that's
i think the smartest thing would be the
supreme court actually hearing it and
then ruling against it
on some you know in some capacity me i
don't know good question
um denying eight states is gonna make
people blow up yeah no it's i didn't
really think about like that angle of it
that makes sense i mean i
i still think ultimately the supreme
court's gonna gonna pass but
i wouldn't be surprised the the the the
uh injunctive relief was nine zero
unanimous they said no yeah
i mean that's not the first time right
the third circuit was but
people are people have commented they're
saying the reason they did that is
because
texas lawsuits is bigger and it's going
to accomplish the same thing and this is
just more forty chess thinking right
like
like like oh this loss is actually what
we want like no we don't want to lose
we're taught losing well no but does
that make sense that the supreme court
would say
we are already lit you know we have a
bigger case that's going to happen
they would have got just gotten the
filing by the time they were i mean they
would have finalized this right
last few days yeah they wouldn't have
known about this filing they would have
just gotten the filing they barely
reviewed the briefing have not reviewed
any opposition
briefing or even thought about it i mean
i think i think the fact that this many
states
have lined up is signaling to the people
of this country
that the divisions are as extreme as
they could possibly be oh i have no
doubt about that i mean the divisions
are
horrible but i think that leads to some
you know really bad scenarios in the
next
few years i hope not i hope you're wrong
v city says related your story earlier
do you remember in 1996 the dnc and
clinton's got busted illegally accepting
contributions
the chinese billionaire doing that got
arrested in 2015 for illegally bringing
4.5 million into the us
that was the john ash case interesting
big rig says what is the definition of a
reasonable amount of time in the context
of the pa lawsuit
uh i mean they're in the pa lawsuit that
would that would relate to lashes
i mean and that would be you know the i
you know there
it's it's a question of whether or not
there was undue delay and that will
differ based on
that's you know under the circumstances
there's a lot of cases in law where
there's not exact technical definition
and then it's like did it cause
prejudice to the opposing party
rylo 704 says he wins in court or
revolution it is that's what everyone
around me in north carolina is thinking
as seen by massive gun ammo sales no one
will tolerate an agent of china as potus
i have a dd214 and i will readily die
for america
do you see what the arizona gop said are
you ready to die for your for your
country or whatever
i mean i i i i'll be actually a little
bit more forcefully i think all that
talk is too much i think
oh i agree but look i'm at a point where
i'm like
we see what's going on with china's
infiltration and this guy bragging about
biden being the backpack we've seen the
story we've seen the laptop we've seen
the emails
we know about the flight on air force
too we know all that's happening it's
not about what i think or you think or
anyone in this room thinks it's about
what regular people have decided a long
time ago
sure i mean and hopefully it's i mean
it's the same sort of talk that was like
i mean
the democrats were pushing that trump
was a russian agent for
so you know a long time this seems like
kind of the analog of that like
you know i don't think i don't think
democrats
i mean there were anarchist democrats
but i don't know the democrats were
talking about a complete revolution the
streets so they were talking about
resistance obnoxiously i don't know
dedicated says what does ian think
about what about what we're talking
about i think that
uh we need a cultural cohesion and it's
not going to come through politics
uh that we need to focus on our art make
some sweet songs and keep doing
shows that's why we're doing the vlog we
want to we want to have fun with lasers
and 3d printers
so um we can create something positive
you know a lot of what we talk about
it's like all negative
like all these yeah i don't like talking
about how
my side is going to lose right it's not
it's not
fun it's not my favorite thing to do or
you know a civil war
you know it was right right we want to
we want to build a laser
and you know i was having a teddy bear
with it i was having so much fun when we
were talking about like the national
emergency declaration i got to go on
you know i was everybody didn't agree
with me but i was like no this will work
here's the statute here's the law here's
why what trump's doing is gonna work
super stoked to talk about that really
not a fan of talking about how trump's
like not gonna win these election
challenges that sucks but but you know
outside of just politics in general
everything's always about some crisis or
some problem yeah even if you're talking
about winning you're talking about a
fight
so that's why i'm like we got to do a
vlog we got to do so we're going to
we're buying farmland we're going to be
doing a lot of stuff here we're also
getting a big farm and we're going to do
crazy stuff there we're gonna build like
dome houses that was luke's idea
and we can make videos about just doing
positive things
teaching people how to be responsible
for themselves and having fun while we
do it
because there's got to be a balance yeah
we can't just talk every night about how
bad everything is are you optimistic
about anything uh i mean i'm optimistic
about
i think i'm honestly optimistic about
like how life is going for me personally
in general
you know i'm still reading a lot of
books i got you know human events is
doing well
um i mean things are going well
personally like there you go i read a
thousand page book on the battle of
midway recently
yeah right on jonathan trudeau says i
have a question
can we have the national guard watch
over the poll counters to make sure
everyone plays by the rules
and if you don't then you get arrested
and then there and then there
and then there and they stay and watch
the ballots till everything is counted
uh
i mean we should have a ballot system
that no one questions
like that should be the end goal i don't
know i don't realize why people like
don't think of that i mean other
countries look at our ballot system
we're like
that's stupid yes like we should have a
ballot system that like
that that's beyond question if that
should be the goal because in a world
especially when we're so polarized i
remember tweeting something along the
lines of isn't it a wonderful time to be
experimenting with
it's entirely possible that throughout
the show we were talking about nonsense
because people were getting the news
while we weren't but someone says scotus
has voted six to three to hear the texas
lawsuit is that true no
i don't think so i haven't seen that yet
i saw it i think i haven't seen it
uh i'm pretty sure that it was just
docketed
yeah right it was just more it was like
last night or whatever no and i mean the
lawsuit was filed this morning i think
but it was docketed it was on the
supreme court's docket and people were
out there saying oh they've agreed to
hear it
right right no they just docketed it
they which is just an acknowledgment
that it was properly filed procedurally
trevor klein says so this is it the free
world has lost the future is red
if biden becomes president you guys
won't have a true election canada is
already effed
i had hoped in you guys now it does not
now it does look long night
i'm not i'm not that depressed
especially if you hold the senate
incumbent presidents generally do worse
in their first in their first
congressional midterm and uh biden is
also going to be 81
in in 2024 and oh it's not like
cognitive decline reverses
so lex murray says i'm laughing so hard
i'm crying don't ever fix ian's mic it
is his mic now
people are saying that your mic is
echoing yes and it's probably it sounds
super low
i don't know why is it echoing maybe the
camera's audio is actually
i think that might be it oh there's
nothing i could do about it welcome to
my world
sorry everyone somebody said lock the
door so we can't come back that wasn't
very nice
[Laughter]
i'm not your buddy guy says dark times
lie ahead of us
and there will be a time when we must
choose between what's easy and what is
right
albus dumbledore has anybody read a book
other than harry potter to be fair that
is wait wait wait hold on hold on hold
on
there are other books yeah yeah yeah
yeah i love i love that it's like
millennials need to learn how to read
books because they only ever read harry
potter
it's replaced the bible is like it's a
common cultural touchstone
seriously you know well it's kind of
annoying to me because i've actually
read the harry potter books and there
are some good lines like that one there
are some very hopeful and inspiring
lines no one ever uses those
they only use the dark ones and they're
really super resisting ones
kalyn r says i put 300 on trump to win
howie report of major voter fraud
arrests in texas biden ukraine video on
youtube
kill chain video and hbo shows exactly
how voter fraud is accomplished
kemp is in it for sitting u.s uh is in
it and for sitting u.s senators
well there's always somebody on the
other side of the bet yep
talbot link says there's people saying
trump supporters should be shaved like
the french ladies that supported the not
the nazis with how many protesters did
that to themselves i foresee a dark
twist on benny hill style stuff going
down
yep tyler danielson says if china runs
the
runs the one world government the
galactic federation will never let us in
or they will because they want they're
like the borg
and their extreme authoritarians who
want just people to be under control
right
there's actually a petition on
change.org right now to label the
galactic federation as a racist
organization for the
exclusion of earth right now
getting a lot of signatures nice
wouldn't it be speciesist and not racist
yeah i don't know what that would be
okay so so is this real ew says scotus
just gave wisconsin michigan
pennsylvania and georgia until december
10th
at 3 p.m to respond to the texas lost i
did see that but that's not exactly new
that that could be i mean that's
obviously something where they would and
again it's not i'm not responding to the
texas lawsuit there's right
to the motion for leave to file and so
like what we saw with pennsylvania
they ordered pennsylvania to respond
pennsylvania did and they said
unanimously you lose reject injective
relief yeah like that that's also
happened a lot where i mean everybody's
been really excited about like
they've the motions they've granted are
like the motions for expedited review
and they've been like we want a victory
we won the right to have
our case dismissed really soon as
opposed to later on like is it is it
possible that what's going on is
everyone's kind of agreed we've got to
string the trump supporters along just
enough
so that they run out of steam because on
election night they're all riled up
right
yeah and if biden won outright people
would explode immediately
but drag it out as long as possible get
their hopes up and then bring them down
then hopes up then bring them down and
slowly get to the point where they lost
i mean otherwise they go nuts i mean
maybe that maybe that's the way it'll
work right maybe you'll just have like
i mean maybe we'll just keep losing
these cases and there you go
shooter 13 says mayor chains sit lightly
upon you
and may posterity forget that you were
ever our
forget that you were our countrymen good
quote who's that
i forget i think it's sam samuel adams
look it up for us somebody says jay jay
says will looks like he's going to cry
if trump wins can you comment on
jre with jack dorsey no it's jack was
jack being deceitful seeing now all the
recent censorship
what was jack back on joe rogan no i
didn't see it
is that what happened was that today not
that i've seen i can comment on jack
with uh
joe with jack dorsey when i was on it
but that was like you know almost two
years ago
is that what they're referring to yeah
can i read this quote real fast oh i see
it yeah
it is from sam adams it says if you love
wealth better than liberty
the tranquility of servitude better than
the animation animating contest of
freedom
go home from us in peace we ask not your
council or arms
crouch down and lick the hands which
feed you may your chain set lightly upon
you may your posterity forget that you
are our countrymen
we have two comments jerome morrow says
i used to like ian but now that he's
demonically possessed i don't know
and um empowering chet said ian is in
his echo chamber in his safe space
we got to fix that we got to fix that
but we'll look at that because we don't
we don't hear it because the input
is on the camera it's not going into the
mixer yeah sounds fine it's actually
really simple you just flick the sound
off on the on the camera when we do that
now
yeah i mean we're a couple minutes out
from from from all going to bed so
you know we'll get it sorted i like
demons by the way as i say somebody said
he sounded like that we can go into it
later like
god yeah like the voice of
i don't think ian god mind that actually
the mics are all correct we hear ian
he sounds yeah reverberating here you
think that's what i've always been like
no no that that that what everyone's
hearing that's actually ian's voice
it's not technical vibrato jj says the
tree of liberty
must be refreshed from time to time with
the blood of patriots and tyrants thomas
jefferson
eli ben says i bet ten thousand dollar
on ten thousand dollars on predict it
for trump to win
still confident i will make bank i i
hope you make all that money
eli i just don't think you will uh yeah
and
would you say that you hope you lose
your money and he makes his money i hope
i lose my money
like i you know i i hope i'm wrong but
i'm also like you know i'm not
again i'm not going to make a public
prediction without putting a bet on it
like this one
especially when everybody's disagreeing
with me so i think that's fair donnie
mason says the left was absolutely
talking
revolution in the streets what else
would you call no justice no peace
defunding the police and nationwide
riots um well i'm not so sure about that
but i remember remember
remember when they were chanting
revolution nothing less i'm pretty sure
that implied they wanted revolution
right i was trying to distinguish
between like the antifa lefties and the
sort of russia truthers
who weren't really right right right
yeah
in a weird way it was like a more
bizarre theory like at least like the
sort of antifa revolution the streets
like there's a coherence to it this the
theory that our billionaire real estate
magnate turned president was really a
secret russian nation yes
that was it was a fun idea it was like
living in a movie you know but life is
more boring than that
let's see jacob jones says gandalf quote
to frodo lamenting bad times
quote so do i and so do all who live to
see such times
but that is not for them to decide all
we have to decide is what we do with
this time that has given us that's great
yeah
true well i think uh you know a little
bit over but uh we'll we'll wrap up
there make sure
you guys hit that like button subscribe
notification bells we'll be back
tomorrow will
thanks so much for hanging out you want
to mention uh your website and
yeah humanevents.com um you know read
our read our news and and follow me on
twitter and periscope at will
chamberlain when
i regularly periscope and i'm doing a
lot of the legal periscopes as legal
news happens
will chamberlain yes you you realize the
first time i was introduced to you
someone
said your name was will chamberlain i
was like wasn't that like a soccer
player like what what
wilt chamberlain yeah yeah no i i i it's
not the first time i've
right i imagine it's like very i was
like i was like that name sounds
familiar
they called him super tall basketball
player basketball player built the stilt
chamberlain
all right well make sure you follow me
on twitter instagram parlor at tim cast
check out my other channels
youtube.comtimcast and
youtube.comcastnews again we're live
monday through friday at 8 pm so make
sure you subscribe hit the notification
bell and
don't forget to follow luke rodkowski
he's chilling here yeah you can find me
on youtube.com forward slash we
are change and i hope to see you there
and of course we got ian who is now the
demonic
monster of god you know
you don't have to do that i don't have
to we're all ready
and of course you got sour patch lids
over on the production station yes i've
been pushing the buttons all wrong
tonight you guys sound
very similar you guys are basically
brothers from different mothers i'm
sorry about that
who sour patch liz um luke and will
you sound very similar your voices so
yeah it's been difficult
interesting anyway here's tim thanks for
hanging out everybody we'll be back
tomorrow at 8 pm and we will see you all
then bye guys
you